good morning
everyone it's February uh 17 2021 it is
901 a.m. uh we are now GA gathering the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee as the chair of the house
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuing to executive
order 2020
d04 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public
hearing potential for executive sessions
to be held throughout please note that
there is no physical locations for
members of the public observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
Emer of order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneous and listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform by Tel all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general
website the notice for this meeting
complies to house rules of RSA
91-b anyone who has a problem accessing
27136 or email HCS
l.st do.
Us in the event of public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting bradel the community
research please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by a roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking
your rooll call attendance each member
states their presence please also State
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting required under
the right to
know
the morning
everyone Vice chairman
Welch here representative Bert yes and
representative Hopper is here with me
representative Hopper yeah like he said
representative
green representative Wallace presid
representative testerman here
representative TR here representative
Pratt yeah representative Marson present
clerk is present representative Harriet
Gat pres representative
pakus presid
representative
oarn representative oarn can you hear me
yep presid
alone representative
or here alone in my room in the
room representative
Muse I'm here and alone in my
office representative
Newman I'm here and my wife is in the uh
house representative
Balden um I'm at home it's it's me two
cat
Conley representative F
Knight
here representative
Bradley here and my two daughters are
with
me chairman abis
the chair is present and and represent
Balden just when you cast your vote
you at this time representative Mar Le
I flag of the United States of America
and to the rep for it stands one nation
all thank you represent
Mar
this time we we open the public hearing
125 represent I don't I don't see that
you signed the testify but I know you
sponsor do you intend on introducing the
bill um thank you for recognizing me Mr
chair um representative Roy um thought
it would be good to uh bring forth this
you chair recogniz representative Terry
Roy
thank you Mr chairman good morning
members of the
committee I once again and before you
asking you to consider a bill um
hp25 if you recall uh we had last year
and passed it out of committee this bill
originated um based on an observance by
the general public that some police
departments were posting post arrest
photographs of arrestes on social media
before they had been convicted of a
crime and we determined that that was
not a good thing because those pictures
once out there stayed there and if a
person were found not guilty or if the
charges were dismissed the pictures were
still out there associated with them of
the crime and it would make future
employment difficulty and and various
other things besides um you know General
embarrassment in the public so we felt
that that was not a good thing so we
passed a very similar Bill to this last
year that prohibited that um I believe
it got caught up in the the Senate
Omnibus um Whirlwind and and didn't go
anywhere so we're bringing it back um I
have offered an amendment I hope
everyone has it this morning um the
amendment I've offered just puts a
little more clarity
into when um the police can
actually release these photos um if
we'll just go over it real quick it's
basically the same thing as last year
but what it says this law enforcement
office May publish post arrest photos
related to a crime for which a subject
has not been convicted if the subject
fails to appear before the court after
having been granted bail or is suspected
of committing a subsequent crime while
on bail and the assistance of the public
is necessary to locate the subject after
routine non-public methods of location
have been exhausted so what that
basically means is if someone's granted
bail and they default on it and don't
show up in court and the police need to
find them and they've used routine
methods such as checking their address
checking their place of work um they
made them publish the photo for the
assistance of the public and looking for
that person and the same applies if the
person commits another crime while
they're on bail and the police needed
assistance in finding
them um It also says law enforcement May
release post arrest photos the subject
presents an imminent immediate danger to
the public and the release of the photo
as necessary for Public Safety um and
there's a numerous scenarios where you
can imagine where someone needs to be
found because they're a danger to their
spouse or to a child or what have you
and the police need to find them so
basically that's the bill in the
amendment in the nutshell I understand
there may be another amendment coming
forth that would impose penalties on the
police for violating this we considered
that option last year and we decided
that it was not a good idea um the the
public has a common law right to sue if
the police violate the laws if there
were is sort of pass implementing a fine
such as $10,000 against the police um
first of all that's probably about a
third or fourth of a of a policeman's
salary when it could be a mistake um so
I feel like leaving that out just
putting the law as it is if they violate
it the person wants to they're free to
Sue and prove their case in court
without um hanging a fine over the law
enforcement
um I I feel that we have a better chance
of getting this through without that in
there so with that I'm open to taking
any
questions represented
new just one quick question do you have
any opposition to the publication of uh
the names of uh of people uh who are
accused of these crimes so would
you uh do you think the publication of
names is acceptable but not the
photos yeah that thank you for the
question representative Muse that that's
a it's a really fine line we walk
because at the same time uh we don't
want the police to be arresting people
in secret and the public have no access
or idea who they're taking or holding so
it's it's a difficult thing I feel like
we're we're kind of we're splitting the
splitting the baby on this one and the
photographs um are easily recognizable
the names are are can be published uh
they're a public record and I think that
the public has a right to know who the
police are taking and holding so yeah
it's it's a difficult question but I I
feel like we're GNA with the picture at
least that's some
you thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
what was the amendment number you were
referring to your Amendment
uh just a
second my amendment number
is
d385
Hy you don't mind forwarding that the
entire committee I did this morning did
anyone get
it let's I did and it might be
0384 oh you said it correctly my
apologies yeah
four I sent it to uh house criminal
Committee I can resend it if You' like
how about I just send it to the
chairman just to make
[Music]
see no further questions I want to thank
representative
T
you just want to remind members of the
public for the purposes of this hearing
W Jon
wheeler if there are any members of the
public that have their hands that wish
hear hello can you hear me yes hear okay
thank you Mr chairman um I just wanted
to speak on this bill very briefly just
because I think that putting a the the
distribution of arrest
photos in the media or in the public
guilty you know I grew up thinking that
uh you know you're innocent until proven
guilty but something like this with the
sensationalization of pictures that go
out in the media of someone who isn't
even convicted of a crime who has just
been
arrested creates the Assumption of
guilty before proven innocent or guilty
before proven anything before the case
has even been deliberated on uh and you
know this is a problem with the media
but it's also something that we can
address here through the legislature uh
and I would hope that members of this
body would vote um to protect civil
liberties and and help people uh avoid
this media sensationalization you know
media sensation uh that can be created
through this type of process so thank
yield representative n you recognize for
a question thank you Mr chair I I
actually have a question for
you um am I allowed to ask questions as
the prime sponsor or only the co-
sponsors can ask questions and if not I
I'd like to just give a brief like one
minute testimony if I could so so I I
will answer the question for you the
prime sponsor is not if the prime
sponsor a member of the committee is not
committed to ask
questions so you would not be able to
ask questions if you would like to
testify we would I would recognize you
to testify after Mr Wheeler done thank
much
seeing No Hands raised Mr Wheeler thank
excuse the chair now recognizes uh
representative
n thank you chairman and thank you um my
members here um I just wanted to add a
couple of few things that um are worth
mentioning this was on consent calendar
last year I approached um representative
Roy and we worked in a bipartisan manner
on this issue for the last uh year and a
half I think that representative
pentakus also worked on this last year
so there was a really good faith effort
in to address this problem I had
constituents reach out to me um one um
had a job and and um driving elderly uh
folks to appointments and such and um
they Googled her and found her arrest
photo um and it was a really long time
ago and they then rescinded her job
offer um and uh this was a dire
situation in which um she had no income
and a and a child and um I I really
don't I I it really hurt that she
couldn't be given a second chance at um
being a member of society I had another
constituent reach out to me um for
something that they did a really long
time ago as well and they were denied
housing um so this is happening in our
state um people are being denied a
second chance after serving their time
or even being Innocent but since some of
these police stations on their Facebook
pages have
sensationalized like I don't know if
it's for morale boosting or what have
you um for for doing a good job but the
the repercussions of posting something
that isn't necessarily um affecting
other people isn't violent or self
Haring um and also before conviction and
and you see a whole town then commenting
and it it it it fuels this mob mentality
where these these people's lives are
suddenly destroyed before they're even
proven guilty or even if um they weren't
and to move on with their lives it's
it's all on the internet forever for
everyone to see so I really think that
compassion needs to be brought back um
to how we notify the public of what's
going on and this bill specifically um
doesn't take away anything that would be
a danger to the public I want to make
that very clear um representative Roy
and I we know we have a duty to inform
the public if there's an uh really D
like somebody's on right now in
Manchester as an example we had somebody
just shoot somebody and kill them and
they're still at large you know that's a
perfect example of yeah share that photo
call hotline we need Public Safety is at
risk right now so that this is this bill
does not get rid of that that is crucial
to understand this bill is specifically
designed for people that are not a
threat to the public and um you know
have minor infractions that that didn't
affect anybody's else's life uh shall we
say so I just want to say that and again
end with this was on the consent
calendar this was a big bipartisan
effort just to give people in our
communities a fair Shake uh isn't
innocent till proven
guilty thank you thank you
representative for your testimony
representative thank you Mr chairman and
and thank you for taking my question
representative uh the first two cases
that you explained about you know the
loans and um or where she worked um were
they convicted or they were just accused
because I think this bill only does
accused
correct
can you um please tell me if you see
that on a certain line so I can jump
up a followup Mr chairman representative
you recognized for a followup thank you
Mr chairman um well no what what I'm
getting at is your first you you said
about this lady that drove for this um
you know for
appointments if I understand the bill
correctly the bill only if you're
accused so I'm just curious was this
lady you know charged and if that's the
case this bill wouldn't have helped her
so I'm just confused on what the
bill I was told she wasn't it was for a
minor driving
infraction um uh
again it's it turns out when we hear
stories from constituents sometimes um
we don't always get the full story but I
did some research um and you know even
if this weren't to help her I'm hoping
this will help others because I have uh
looked at Facebook responses of of
different uh
police uh police offices around our
state and I I'm saddened that this is
starting to become a trend on social
media so I have I have seen this
multiple times from multiple different
police uh departments so I'm not I can't
accurately say if this bill would have
helped her I'd like to believe it would
I don't have the entire story on that
part but I've had heard complaints in
regards to this and like I said I've
seen the post and I just don't think
it's fair I don't think that you can
tell the public one thing you can say
watch out for this person they're a
danger but to Poe somebody that's not a
danger or risk to society shame them
either for mental health issues
substance use disorders and then get
keep the comments open it's one thing to
also notify the public but then have a
whole the comment section open so people
can say the most abhorent things uh and
take away someone's Humanity um this is
really that's the intent this bill so I
hope it would help her um I I realized
there was a problem when she came to me
her specific case though I I cannot say
raised see no hands raised
representative may your excuse thank you
meaza laskas excuse me yep no problem
let's SK yep thank thank you Mr chair in
the committee for hearing my testimony
today my name is Joseph laskas I am the
smart Justice organizer for the American
civil liberties Union of New Hampshire
and I will be testifying in support of
this legislation
today
um there's there's many things that have
been said already uh concerning uh mug
shots and what that means when it's
pre-conviction uh a mug shot captures an
individual when they're often at their
worst moments in um in life and they are
taken at a time when people are supposed
to be presumed innocent and often times
there is a a stigma um of assumed guilt
that happens or comes with a mug shot
being
taken and if mug shots are publicly
released before conviction there is no
way to revoke them if the person is
acquitted or charges against them are
subsequently dropped later on so instead
a mugshot will live um you know
indefinitely online and it will follow
individuals even after their cases have
been resolved and you know and taken
care
of I do you know I
I could I could go more into that but I
just wan to I do want to say this that
in 2005 I I myself have been had my mug
shot put on the front page of a
newspaper and in 2005
um my mother ended up in CMC Hospital
for several days because the first time
she found out from a stressinduced heart
attack from seeing my mug shot on the
newspaper before I was convinced IED so
it's not just the individual um who
Presumed Innocent that
uh that suffers but also people around
them um as well I do want to I do want
to you know state that the ACLU strongly
does support chapter 91a and does
believe in public
transparency however uh this is one of
the rare cases where the Public's
interest in someone's mug shot is
outweighed by the prejudicial nature of
a mug shot before there's even been a
convict
and mug chubs do not provide any
information that cannot be obtained from
a police report or any other written
materials and I do want to say if the
Press wants a photo of someone who has
been arrested there's no reason why they
cannot attend the arraignment or any
other court proceedings that will happen
and get their pictures there um and we
would not be the only state to do this
New York has restricted uh similar
access to mshot information though this
legislation is more targeting in so far
as it's limited to pre-conviction mug
shots um I do want to state that this
bill does not prevent law enforcement
from releasing the details of an arrest
including someone's name as was stated
earlier and it it only restricts the
release of a pre-conviction mug shot
which is uniquely
prejudicial uh this bill does allow for
a disclosure pre-conviction where the
subject of the photo is a fugitive from
Justice as was stated and if they pose
an immediate and ongoing danger to
Public Safety where disclosure is
necessary to convey a witness or police
officers in the performance of any valid
law enforcement
function so for these reasons and more I
support this legislation the ACLU New
Hampshire supports this legislation and
we hope that you will vote a to pass I'm
questions thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
representative
Hopper point of our order Mr chairman
what's the time limit for testimonies or
is there one today you're recognized for
a point of order the chair is setting a
TW minute time limit however our next
public hearing is until
9:45 so there it is at the discuss chair
to allow a witness to go beyond that
because there was no one signed up to
testify with their hands
raised U I love two witnesses to
actually go well beyond the time limit
but when we are in time constraint that
you seeing no members of the public with
their hands
[Music]
raised now close the public hearing on H
Bill
and Mr chair we had uh uh signing in in
support of the bill uh were 94 people
order uh Mr chairman I keep hearing a
telephone if somebody could mute that
telephone if that keeps going off that
would be very appreciative I think it's
disruptive of the committee here
although I agree that that telephone
going off is extremely disruptive I
don't
think but whoever's telephone is on
dat generally speaking we're not
supposed to use electronic devices in
the room obviously we have the
exceptions because we're
all so please be respectful thank we'll
this
e
yes
are you
ready can you hear
us I don't think home he us I don't
there D can you hear I can hear you yes
you
guys
right at this time the criminal justice
Public Safety Committee we will open the
public hearing on House Bill 129 the
chair recognizes representative
testman thank you Mr chair uh I'm
representing Dave testerman I'm from
mayor act two area uh represents
Hill I introduced this bill because uh a
few months ago or actually more than a
few months
ago Apple loaded a uh app on your iPhone
if you have an iPhone and Ed it it did
not activate it but what it was it was
for locating you and times of
co uh and I objected to the fact that
they could actually activate it without
me knowing and I looked into it and
there are apps like this which
would activate when you're within a few
feet of another person who also had a
similar uh piece of software and the
need for it was to effectively put a
Scarlet a on your forehead so that if
you uh had a vaccination or didn't have
a vaccination or you know you had you'd
been tested positive for uh co uh they
could notify a person in close proximity
of you uh that you know you were uh a
deplorable uh and I objected to this so
that's what this bill does it says if
you're going to put that kind of a
software on and activate it you need to
let the person know now I what worries
me and I don't know how to cure it is
that even with that we all get software
on we just keep saying okay okay with
licenses and we seldom ever read them so
I can probably get uh burn on this
particular uh app if I'm not careful but
I I wanted to make this abundantly clear
that this kind of of an application in
New Hampshire is not
take represented true you recognized for
a question thank you Mr chair thank
thank you representative for taking my
question um nobody's going to sneak an
app onto my
phone
but in this in this
case the app could be on your phone when
you've got a a new a new
phone I'm old enough to had some some
older phones and I don't know if there's
any if they can be updated at
I
representative TR you recogniz for a
followup question than Mr chair no what
I meant is somebody goes out and buys a
new phone a brand new phone that does
everything do those phones could those
phones come with this app that you
wouldn't know
of
yes since the these companies who make
these phones send out updates to the
software there's one I was talking about
just showed up one day on my phone but
panus thank you representative for
taking my
question is this bill saying that um no
one can have this kind of app on their
phone in the state of New
Hampshire says nobody can have it on
their phones if they don't want
it it can be on the phones and there can
be some percentage of the people who
would have it but it says that if
they're G to put it on
know thank
you
representative
news just had a question about um how
you how you knew uh the app was actually
installed to your phone and did have you
deleted
it
uh the app
was when you went back into the in into
the settings and so on
there was a
location
uh button you could turn on uh if you
wanted to accept that kind of app the
only way I found out about it was
reading some technical journals and I
told me where to look and I said yeah
it's
me representative use you recognize for
a
followup was the app activated without
your knowledge so uh uh did you confirm
that you were actually being tracked by
the
app it was not activated it Apple
knowing that it would be
controversial didn't they installed it
but they didn't turn it
you representative Bradley recognize for
a question thank you chair
um do you use the easy pass that the
state gave
do you recognize for a fall off question
um did you know there's a Tracker in the
Easy Pass I
you representative giz for a question I
know that that there's a group that you
could report this to I don't know
whether it's the FCC or it might be have
on I thought I would do it just in the
states I mean at the state level my
experience in trying to get something
through the federal agencies like FK and
so on has been been has not been very
successful so I didn't do I
didn't tell them that they couldn't do
it there's no there's no way for me to
stop them from putting it
on there is maybe a way to stop them
from
activating from making making me
knowledgeable whether they've
activ
option
representative
Bon thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question do
I understand correctly that the exposure
notifications app on the iPhone is not
functional in New Hampshire as it
requires the active
participation of DHHS and they've
announced no intention uh to participate
in this
app
I don't know if DHHS is I but I don't
want to wait for somebody's intentions
you know i' I'd like to see it stopped
tracked representative B you recognized
for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative so basically what you
want if I'm hearing correctly is is when
Google you know follows
us U and you know sells that information
you want them to clearly tell us that
they're doing that but then you know
what are you going to do about the NSA
that's doing the same thing I can't stop
everybody I can just raise a hand and
say I really don't like
thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent taking my question or twoing
so reading the propose LSR you have in
testimony can you speak up please can
you hear
me yes please speak
louder unless I'm
yelling you don't mind okay can you hear
me now yes okay so in reading your uh
proposed LSR and listening to testimony
uh I'm trying to understand how in the
LSR it says that uh no person shall
without consent Place locate or install
an electronic device as we all know that
those phones are not really manufactured
in New Hampshire uh and come pre uh
downloaded with these apps unless you
specifically download an another app so
how based on this are we looking to
enforce
this thank you for the question
uh the way I would enforce it is uh each
phone store or person selling a phone in
New Hampshire would have to have the
ability uh to go in and and turn it off
uh and when they're bringing a phone
into New Hampshire not when when a
company is trying to sell a phone in New
Hampshire they would know that for New
Hampshire we have to have certain
difficult
follow ask for a followup
question well thinking of that
terminology most uh phones that I have
bought uh have been um sealed and most
customers would want a phone that hasn't
been already opened and uh taken out and
unload
uh turned on I guess would be would you
bre thank you the question or the
comment the the way I would would see it
is if I go to the
local Apple Store uh when I picked up
the phone from them they would take it
out just to
and you know would would help me set it
up and part of the setup would be
shutting that off if I didn't want
it it it's not going to be easy and I
would like to make it difficult for the
manufacturers to install this hopefully
that representative green thank you Mr
chair uh representative Testament do you
know two questions is one is when did
you realize that this took half took H
when it happened that you saw it on
there and is it also on all phones other
Amazon just try to limit one
question
I I I realized it when I read about it
last summer time frame and uh and it was
specific to an iPhone I don't know
whether Android has it but I suspect
that they would probably follow suit if
they don't haven't already done it and I
just checked and yes this particular
kind of software this switch to to
there recogniz for a followup question
thank you Mr chair uh did you take it to
an Amazon store and see if they could
you seeing no further hands
raised
represent last question
thank and please speak up we will not
take offense if we feel that you're
yelling I'll try to maybe use a
different device after this uh what is
the penal
if they do not
comply excuse me I I didn't understand
you what is the penalty if they do not
comply with this I don't have one
one representative KN recognize for a
question
um thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question um don't you think
it's the consumer's responsibility to
understand the product they're buying
and know how to operate it and use its
functions I fully agree that's why I'm
asking they can install this software at
least if they if they fully
inform the the consumer that it's there
and that they can either turn it on or
turn it off so I I agree with you
P followup
chair now you recognize for a followup
question are you aware that there's
already information before buying this
product on labels and signed contracts
to notify the consumer of of of exactly
these functions I I'm not I
I know there's a lot of times we all
install stuff on our our phones our
computers and it says you know
acknowledge that this license says
something and we just go ahead and and
you know push the next button so I know
a lot of people won't worry about this
uh but I'd like to be notified if they
do
it
thank
you thank you see no further hands
repres seeing no members of the public
with their hands
raised represent new you want to read
the
numbers
[Music]
M sorry Mr chair I I uh I I didn't uh
download that particular one and I just
need to find it very quickly here it
is
um
on hb29 we had uh eight people signing
in in support and five people signing in
in
opposition thank you
represent at this time we now close the
public hearing on postfield
[Music]
129 at this time the chair is now
opening the executive session on Bill
on on the 17th day of February
a
second
59 sorry
579 wall would you like you recognize to
second that motion thank you Mr chairman
Mo wish to speak anyone wish to speak on
this
[Music]
motion
Reon we could Advance this to the house
more I would just say
that inle with both of respons of the
bill I believe the intention of this
bill is good and I hope that this
committee will work on fixing the notice
requirement which is the notice issue
was
uh I don't believe the notice provision
as written in the proposed bill would
have been
effective I think that we need to sit
down get this right and and I did with
the sponsors on this and they on board
with
representa Marson thank you Mr
chairman looking at looking over my
notes it's probably my mistake but we
supported
information and I would have to go back
and check my email on that one
doing
this
time we'll see no further hand raised
for the discussion uh now now to put the
question on the motion to retain Mr I I
do have an answer to uh uh to the
representative's question on uh HB
579 uh 205 people signed in in support
of this bill and nine people signed in
position see no further hands raised to
CL up call a roll if you in support of
the motion to rain please say yay if you
are opposed please say
next Vice chairman Welch yes
representative Bert yes representative
Hopper yes representative green yes
representative Wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative TR yes representative
Pratt yes representative Maron yes clerk
votes yes representative Harriet GA no
office
muted L are you muted
repres you need to unmute yourself for
the
[Music]
vote representative pus you need to
unmute your
nay
down representative o'n
yes representative bord yes
representative muse no
representative Newman
no representative
Balden no all right representative
Conley no representative Klein Knight
no Representative
panellus
no chairman sorry about
yes
13 by a vote of 13
we will close the executive session on
579 the chair is now opening the
195 for the record it is the 17th day of
recogn
motion yes Mr chairman I make a motion
195 Maron second that the motion pass
by yes I would um listening to the
testimony on this bill there seem to be
um over over displaying or hysteria and
I think that there's a huge difference
between displaying a firearm to prevent
something if you are being threat to
dispense that threat versus walking into
Reckless we now open the question for
discussion
see no hands
raised the matter we question Mr chair
excuse
me Mr chairman I have to oppose this uh
motion off the pass uh we have no
definition for display firearms and is
very ambiguous um so I can't uh support
law represent
news yes Mr chairman we also heard uh
testimony uh that the difference between
display uh and brandishing uh is very uh
ambiguous it's not something that's
actually defined in our statute I know
we spent a lot of time on that on the
public hearing but but I think one of
the the more persuasive pieces of
testimony that I heard uh was when the
topic of corve control was discussed so
in essence the the very act of showing
somebody a firearm in a confrontational
situation um is an act of conser of
coercive control um and one of the
reasons why this is in our statute now
is this this is an act of violence uh
and this is something that uh should not
be removed from our statute it's
place Senator
Baron thank you Mr chairman there was no
amendments to this bill I'm trying to
recall if that was
Su there's been no amendments presented
you representative
Newman thank you Mr chairman I'm opposed
to this bill also um my main fear is
that uh when we have people displaying
guns and road rage incidents um it seems
like a very dangerous situation to me
you get one display one then the other
one will have a shootout on one of the
roads um I think it's just a very
it representative
Knight
thank you chairman um I'm opposed to it
as well I remember asking the question
of one of the
sponsors um what his intent was and he
said he wanted to scare people so they
wouldn't uh escalate things and he also
stated he'd respect somebody that would
try and scare him brandishing or um
displaying their firearm as well um I I
just don't feel comfortable with the the
intent that that was given to us on the
record by the sponsors I think that this
is has very dangerous consequences and
hasn't been uh thought out properly and
um I I I will say that if this were to
pass I could see a major increase in
deaths going up due to firearms in our
representative
wel I would only suggest
that and a good example of a
display would be you're walking down the
street somebody comes out of an alley
and says empty your
pockets you open your coat and show that
you are
on and curent and the guy runs down the
street grabs the C and says this guy
Just sh me with a fire on
that's not the way it's supposed to be
the criminals are supposed to be the
ones who get caught not the victims and
display it's already in
statute 631 col
4 Page
584 in our
book I think this just a continuation of
something that we put in place several
years ago when what bird up in
molbo got
convicted of threatening a woman who had
trespassed on his property he never
showed the gun but it was in his uh in
his belt in the back of him when he
turned around to go in the house she saw
the gun and went down to the police
station and turned him in he got
convicted that was that's why we have
something in 6314
now
I'm definitely against um supporting
this bill one of the things that the
same the day that we heard this in the
hearing I was online and looking up the
definition of brandish and sort of was
waiting till we got to this point um
synonym flash trout out we display
this port and that's literally in the
dictionary so for you to say that
display anything other than brandish I
you so in regards to display versus
brandish that's when I first read looked
at this bill I I had to same concern
under the federal
definition paraphrasing but
brandishing is when you display a
firearm and it's coupled with a
threat and that threat is particularly
meant to intimidate some New Hampshire's
been an open carry state as long as I
can remember before long before was a
constitutional
carrier open carrying is as a example of
displ hearing a lot of the the testimony
comments is really I watch reason why I
support this bill because what I'm
hearing is that anytime someone displays
a fire on people are considering it a
threat and that's the exact problem in
the law that this is intended to fix and
for that I would be supporting the
motion
ofes representative hoer thank you Mr
chair um I'd like to to uh Del into this
idea of fors of control my grandson's 6'
one and he's pretty strong so when he
asked me for a to stop at
Subway I could think that that's force
of control but it really isn't I mean we
we there's people the examples used are
people that have a gun are in a dominant
situ
position but that's really true
throughout our lives always situation
where there is somebody in in the room
that is more dominant or in control
right now you're the chairman of the
committee so is that course of control I
mean I I think it's
um unrealistic to think that we aren't
there isn't full birth of control
throughout our lives and we have to
thanks
thank you Mr chair i' mentioned some
time before when we were discussing this
that there are people and I do know some
people that would not shoot a person but
they carry an empty gun it's not loaded
and this would be a way for them further
themselves
um can you um how many people supported
it and how many opposed it that day I
didn't bring my notes
from last week I have that answer thank
you represent
Marson according to Muse at the time I
wrote down
represent sorry
represent
yes he said supported it was 42 opposed
was
thank
you
chairman during a lot of these standard
ground bills we we heard a lot of people
testify and say well I'm sure that it's
you know it's traumatizing to people
that been in this situation
but but I'm afraid but what about my
feelings
I think everybody needs to step
back because you are that person that is
being
threatened or your loved one is being
threatened and you're the one that has
the ability to stop it with just showing
the handle of a
firearm you're the good
guy you are the good
guy walking
in to negotiate a contract and taking
out your firearm and plac on the table
well now you're a
jerk but using a
tool as representative bden had stated
not all tools are meant for everybody to
use right her husband might not be great
with the chainsaw but mine is and if I
have the ability and I'm trained and I
know how to use my firearm and so do
everybody in my family we should be able
to use it and let me just also say that
if I'm in a convenience store with any
single person in this room
room and someone's trying to threaten
your life I will protect you by showing
that I can that is all thank
you representative
Bradley um thank you chairman I will be
voting against this bill I think it's
dangerous I think it's unclear of what
um you know we keep talking about
display and brandishing but it's still
not clear and rep roads I app appreciate
that you do get training I think that's
that's fantastic but not everybody does
and when I go to the grocery store if
I'm bumping into somebody and they turn
around and show me something and I have
my two kids with me that's scary I don't
care and I appreciate that you took the
time to get trained I have no idea what
type of training that person has and all
I want to do is go grab eggs and milk
and now I am worried so I appreciate
what you've said but it's a slippery
slope and if everybody has a chance to
be walking around brandishing or
displaying a
weapon I mean what are we asking for
this is this is
ridiculous um that's that's I just think
this is a scary bill this makes no sense
it
just my
perspective
1986 1987 as far as I can remember
always and I think the concern is that
by open carrying you are disppointed a
fire and it's it's a lawful act and it
always has been simply to open car
before it became a constitutional carry
state if you didn't have a you actually
had the open car the per was to conceal
so open caring is is is a traditional
long exercise but what I'm hearing is
that people find that act to be in of
itself threaten and which would then if
you're displaying and threatening
someone you are now brish now I will say
personally I I I don't open car I I
don't find need to and to be honest most
people don't but it doesn't mean that
it's simply if someone is open caring
they
threat so I mean police officers do it
on a regular basis a public trust
there I just I'm just explaining that
this is something that the difference
between brandishing and displaying needs
to be distinguish displ does not involve
KN thank you I really appreciate
representative Road's passion on this I
share a similar passion but for the
opposite opinion I feel as someone who
has been
threatened uh multiple times in my life
I
feel that everyone also has a right at
least in my district to feel
safe and I've heard
overwhelming amount of my constituents
reach out to me
that this bill makes them feel less safe
and I heard that was the intent also of
the bill if I hear a legislator that's
saying their intent is to scare people
and we have overwhelming amount of
numbers of our own people and by the way
Mr chair with all due respect for both
sides on a bipartisan issue you can
change the form we should be requiring
people to the state they're from the
city in the zip code and it's on record
that they're telling the truth and we
need to amend that form the sign and
Sheet immediately for both bipartisan
reasons and I have to say that if we can
determine people in New Hampshire and
we're representing them and hearing
their voices those numbers those are
facts that's the data and also yes you
have a right to protect yourself and yes
you know what it's already there in in
the Constitution that you can do this we
can't determine how many people are
trained we want to bring more guns for
them where there was no data on and then
there was no necessary requirements on
how to use this uh tool properly there
there's just a complete Black Hole when
it comes to accountability on this law
and that means you can get away with
murder and that scares people and I just
want to make that really clear that you
can protect yourself but other people
they have a right also to feel safe and
be protected by their representatives
and vouch for for for the things that
they need to continue their lives and go
to the grocery store without feeling
like all of a sudden everybody has a gun
other just may the record reflect when
it comes to the sign and chief chair has
no Authority or discre
to so if there's any issues with the
signning sheet I
would I'm not the person that needs that
needs to be
correct thank you Mr chair a followup on
that I was just told that um you that
each uh committee is different and you
have backend access or somebody does at
least to help you and require more
information on the signin sheet you can
you can
that need to be
recognized I I Envision we'll have a lot
of C discussions in this room so it's
this helpful if people
pakus thank you Mr chairman I'd like you
to clarify for me what this Bill does
I'm hearing from other people that if
open that people are getting AR RIS is
this what they're
saying
so what I what I what this will do it's
RSA
631 three a person is guilty of Reckless
conduct
if if recklessly engages in conduct
which places or may Place Another in
danger of serious
B and what this is do what this fill
would do is that by simply displaying a
firearm you would not be considered to
be engaging in Reckless contu as defined
under RSA
3 mere fact that you're displaying your
firearm which is either showing in whole
or in part or letting it be known
verbally that you are carrying you don't
even have to display you don't even
actually have to physically
show that in and of itself will not
up yes I I really I'm going to vote
against this bill because I don't think
anyone should be allowed to take a gun
out and aim it at some even if they
don't intend to hurt them this is bad
and it's not good for the future of this
of this state thank you represent thank
you I I will just say I this is my
opinion I believe if someone were to
point a firearm at someone that would uh
go beyond the level of displ that's and
that would be Reckless cond because the
when it comes to and I'm not an expert
on firearm training but I know that you
never point the firearm at any person or
anything unless you intend on on
shooting it
so if someone were to do that I think
I believe representative
Welch would speak to that he repres
case I was
there what is happening is when by
simply displaying a firearm people have
been charged with recondo simply for
firearm Mr
chairman yes could we get some data on
bill I don't have any data on it but I
believe we're in the executive session
so the intends to vot
today thank
you
wel yeah Laura is this is to answer your
questions I know you were in the
committee when we did
this but on page
584 halfway down the left hand side this
existing statute says a person who
responds to a threat which would be
considered by a reasonable person is
likely to cause serious bodily injury or
death to the person or to another by
displaying a firearm or other means of
self-defense with the intent to W away
the person making the threat shall not
have committed a criminal act under this
section that's the existing statute and
all this does is address Reckless
conduct on on the previous
par thank
you representative B thank you Mr
chairman um Mr chairman I'm definitely
going to support this
uh I agree there's a lot of people that
disagree with people open carrying but I
open carry all the time I go to the
supermarket I go to Walmart Target uh
Home
Depot um and I did have a small incident
uh this kid you know he was 20 something
years old um and he was cutting across
Lots on my private property behind my
shed and and he to be honest he kind of
startled me when I saw him I was like oh
what's going on and he looks at me and
he says oh I'm just cutting through and
I said well that's what the road's for
you know you aren't supposed to be
cutting through private property so we
had a nice
conversation but when he looked down
because I was open carrying that day and
he saw the the sidearm he goes oh hey
sir um I said well don't worry about it
it's an honest mistake you know just
don't do this you don't walk through
private
property you know at that point he he
moved on I it was all over um but what
happens if it was somebody that went and
reported me for having my sidearm on my
hip as threatening which I didn't you
know and that's what concerns me and
that's why I support this bill because I
don't want to get caught up caught up in
anything like that um you know because
I'm a peaceful man I carry a gun for my
self- protection and my family um you
know I pray every day not to ever ever
ever use it but I want that option and
um you know so that's why I support the
you
see seeing no further hands raised
computer he's wav yeah I apologize Mr
chair I just for the people who are
remote oh sorry it's my computer my
apologize
represent thank you um I think the issue
for me Isn't So Much carrying a weapon
openly and and I think we're kind of
confusing the issue here a little bit um
open carry uh for better or worse uh is
something that is part of our law um the
problem that I have is when you're
carrying a weapon and you call attention
to the weapon uh for the purpose of
basically coercing people into some some
coercing a person into some type of
different Behavior or winning the
argument um I think that's that's a big
issue uh it's one thing to do what
representative Bert did which which is
to carry a weapon around on his own
property that that's fine that's
something you're freely allowed to do in
New Hampshire uh but when you call
attention to that for the purpose of
changing the behavior of another person
and and I and I use as an example I
think you know we we hear a lot about
the defensive example of somebody who
might be threatening to you or somebody
who might be presenting a threat to you
but uh we're also in a situ situation or
we're going to be in a situation
hopefully soon where we have people
coming back to the legislative office
building and testifying so you know one
of the issues is that um Firearms are
allowed in the legislative office
building and so it's perfectly possible
that U you know all of us could f
you know people sitting out there in the
audience um who are opening up their
codes and letting us know just sort of
what they think of us as we sort of vote
up or down on certain bills and I I
think if you take a look at it it it at
the broad range of examples um I think
you can really sort of see the wisdom of
leaving the statute the way that it is
uh and uh and not passing this Bill
raised representa harer just a quick one
Mr chairman thank you um I might have
remembered this incorrectly but I think
one of the testimonies we heard when the
bill was presented was a case I believe
it was in Manchester where a woman was
being attacked out in the driveway in
the
boyfriend and or husband came out and he
grabbed his handgun on the way down to
defend her and he was uh I believe
arrested for brandishing when he never
pointed it at anybody but he used it as
a tool to try
to protect his his loved so I think
that's that's what this bill is
attempting to do is to make sure people
like that aren't arrested for just
[Music]
raised you guys
HT matter will we put the question
motion on the floor the motion right now
is B the
pass if you are in favor please say
nay Vice chairman Welch yes
representative Bert yes representative
Hopper yes representative green yes
representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Mar
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet G no Representative pantelakis
no Representative oarn
no Representative
bordon
Newman
no representative Balden
no representative Conley
no representative kly Knight no
representative Bradley no chairman abis
the chair votes yes Mr chairman the vote
is 11 yay 10
nay I vote of 11 yays 10 Nays the motion
on
pass
majority
report would you like the majority yes
thank you m CL will someone be doing a
Minority
record
step up a l in regard these reports
thank
you this time we will close the
195 committee will be in recess for
three
minutes
I
here
for
e
[Music]
surpris
morning we opening the public
hearing
youing uh yes thank you so
much to speak and just before we begin
testimony I want to remind members of
the public that their testimony will be
limited to to one minute per
witness in members of thee we have
limited two questions per
witness it does not apply to the
[Music]
represent
recognized
thank you so
much uh so thank you
members I uh know you've heard a lot
from me today I'll try and make this
brief um I'm not sure how many of you
were aware a couple months back um there
was a situation in
Manchester uh where we had a a large
displaced community that had um nowhere
to go a and they um made camps up at the
courthouse in Manchester and
um the state didn't did not quite know
how to handle the situation and there
was no real
um plan on how to execute uh a a fair
way to relocate people or get them the
proper help that they need I uh was
there
personally I was there every day I think
all but one I think I was actually in
committee or had some other state duties
I was there when they started to erect a
fence around this Courthouse
property um and a bunch of state police
showed up to make sure things ran
smoothly now the fence was uh getting
thing set up at a very fast response and
as that was happening um the residents
of this area were notified that their
stuff um was going to be thrown away um
if they could not move it in time um
they did not wait for the fence to be
erected they um immediately started
throwing um people's possessions away
and um this was this situation was a
extremely blown out due to the pandemic
so we have seen a major increase in uh
houseless people across the state and a
lot in our city areas where uh they
can't we can't afford apartments and um
landlords just some of them just don't
care and it is what it is and so getting
back to people congregating here all
their worldly possessions um in one spot
um I remembered speaking to one of the
women there um she had medications
social security
card um something from her grandmother I
mean I'm talking about the last worldly
possessions to her name and a backpack
um and while there was a couple of us um
there to Bear witness and try to
scramble and save as as much of these
belongings for people as possible it was
utter chaos and there was a lack of
dignity given to us by the police um
there was at least three to four
officers standing near me um we spread
out to help each individual as much as
we could and I'm a 5 foot two woman I
don't have much upper body strength but
there was this cart that was really
close to the people erecting this fence
and as these three huge very strong men
stood there and laughed at me I
scrambled to push this person's
possessions to safety and it was a lie
it was a tent it was a lot of a lot of
weight and in a shopping cart um it was
a lot and I couldn't do it and I fell
over and they laughed at me and they
said you almost got it and and you
better hurry and I was not treated like
a human being in that moment and I can
only imagine
what the people that have fallen onto
less fortunate circumstances must feel
about being treated in that position and
I think that as a state I'm really
ashamed of how our officers acted in
that moment and I think there was a lack
of response from our state
and lack of resources and training our
officers on how to handle this situation
and we need to address it it's our
responsibility to do that it's just it's
it's a situation where we've put our
police officers in
that we don't have a system for for them
to be trained on so how can we expect
them to handle this with the dignity
that people deserve maybe they were
uncomfortable who knows know who can say
the whole experience was very
traumatizing for everybody involved
especially the people that got their
entire worldly possessions thrown away
and I just think that we need to make
training available we need to Showcase
this incident in particular for due
process of people what if you became
homeless what what if you were in that
situation what are your rights um how do
is is it really quite necessary to throw
away everything and incarcerate you on
the taxpayer's money when maybe there
should be mental health and substance
use um advocacy and resources for these
people how much money are we really
spending by continuously incarcerating
the homeless and not maybe putting money
to another uh resource that we can
rehabilitate these people in and that's
what this bill is designed to do we've
heard continuous testimony in this
committee already from the lack of data
that our police officers in the state
gather and we are shooting ourselves in
the foot here by by by not studying this
and in providing dignity and morality to
this issue which is increasing right now
it's it's it's it's an emergency and I
ask you to please take it with all due
consideration that it deserves
thank
you your testimony represent your
recognize for a question uh thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for taking my
question um representative if I
understood right and read the union
leader correctly um on the state
property of the courthouse uh Governor
sonunu did offer them uh some assistance
in Dairy but I I don't know everything
on that
but what my question
is is Mayor the Manchester mayor
Craig of the man you know the Manchester
mayor um is she having the police the
Manchester
police
studied as they went on mayor Craig's
first day in office down on the
Riverbanks and removed all of the
homeless off the Riverbanks and forced
them up on Elm Street and other parts of
the city are they doing a you know a
study on the Manchester police is the
mayor doing that I believe there's been
more uh calls for transparency on the
Manchester police as well and speaking
to this incident in particular this was
a State Police
Issue so I'm just trying to focus on
this this is a state issue the police in
question that removed the homeless and
threw away all their belongings were
state police the police that laughed and
mocked me while I fell on the ground and
hurt myself for at least three weeks
because I've had at least two three
surgeries on my knee they laughed at me
they humiliated me they treated me less
than human and this is something that
needs to be taken serious the whole
state including all cities and towns so
if you're referring to an interest of
doing this at the city level too I
representative you recognize for
followup thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you representative for taking my
follow-up
question if if if that happened and and
I do believe you um you know that's
terrible that you know any officer would
treat anybody especially in that
situation because that's got to be hired
on the homeless you
know you know and again I just go back
to
Manchester were you part of helping the
homeless and is
Craig doing a study on the Manchester
police when they went down under the
amamos bridge just like a week ago and
forced everybody out onto the street
again um you know I've been following uh
Joe Kelly Lasser and he's posting these
pictures that are just horrific in my
eyes of what the mayor is instructing
the police and the town officials or the
uh Department of Public Works to remov
in these homeless people they got a live
somewhere and is a question there yes I
was just wondering if she was part of
helping that yes let me try and answer
that thank you so much as far as I know
Joe Kelly Lasser has never really taken
an interest in the homeless population
he's consistently worked against it and
if you have the time and you're
interested in more information on this
issue I suggest that you start to attend
some of the alderman meetings where they
are discussing this and they are
gathering information and I know they're
doing everything in their power right
now to get more data as far as the
state's concerned I think that we
continuously bury our heads in the sand
and make excuses why we can't gather
data and that is why I think it's a
state responsibility and a city
responsibility so I'm saying yes I agree
with you representative but I think we
also need to make sure that this is
conducted at the city level by passing
this
bill
representative
H thank you Mr chairman
um bringing us back to the issue of uh
of the police for just a second uh to
what extent do you feel that it's it's a
complicating issue uh for the police
that a fair percentage of the people who
are homeless um have other problems like
mental health issues does that compound
the the situation in your
opinion uh yes it does what I'm most
concerned is that our taxpayers are
continuously paying for people with
mental health and substance use misuse
disorders or other a whole other slew of
of health issues and what we're doing is
instead of addressing those medical
conditions or resources for assistance
on living a life that doesn't include
being homeless uh we
instead we we instead spend that money
on
continuously inciting them giving them
um fines and then when they can't pay
that on compounding on top of that then
we incarcerate them so we are literally
paying for this problem to keep
happening um and in my honest opinion
like I said data is really important for
us to make
these good decisions on how to better
operate our state and and make sure that
everybody's being treated fair and that
we're not just hemorrhaging our
taxpayers money on some on a system
that's not working and and I think we
can all agree that no matter how you end
up homeless or displaced that you should
be treated with some sort of
dignity and I didn't see that and I'm
talking to you from a witness that was
there and I had cops laugh at
Police representative test thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representing um you keep
talking
about the state police as being the
perpetrator
you're but the
bill says law enforcement so I'm
assuming you want all kinds of law
enforcement look at in this and also you
say the criminal justice
system is that
true yes just going back to what
representative Bert said this is a
necessary study committee to ga data so
we're not wasting our taxpayers money
and we're not making lives worse it is
our responsibility as the criminal
justice Committee of the State of New
Hampshire to make sure our system is
working for our taxpayers and for the
purposes of correct Rehabilitation there
is a major black hole here I'm not
asking for us to pass anything I'm
data
representative harer thank you Mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question this doesn't seem to be
a a situation that's unique to newshire
do you know if this has already been
studied
elsewhere when you say it's not unique
to New Hampshire are you talking about
other states um can you please um
clarify uh yeah
Mr
chair representer please you may clarify
for the witness um yes thank you Mr
chair um in other words the homeless
situation is not unique to New Hampshire
how to deal with it is also as likewise
not unique to do you know of studies
that have already been done around the
country as to how the most effective way
to deal with the homeless situation
yes um they have there's a lot of other
studies that have been done in um
communities with major displacement
issues and usually it's um
more we have to offer more resources and
we don't do that here and I brought to
this argument to the floor a lot and
people just say well there's no proof
and it's a circular argument then so if
you're telling me that I can't get this
data to prove to you that there's a need
then you're just not going to go for it
but then when I try to get data you
won't let me get data to prove that
there is a need so I think this is New
Hampshire specific I think that we don't
operate just like every other state and
that has been made by you as well I've
heard as your other testimony from my
colleagues is that New Hampshire's
unique we need to do our own research
and we need to hold ourselves
accountable as Leaders to make sure
we're not wasting our taxpayers monies
worse thank you seeing no further
questions represent you're excused I
testimony
before before we begin calling members
of the public to testify I want to
remind members of the public that the
purposes of this hearing your testimony
is limited to one minute and one minut
after one minute expires you your
aren hi thank you um yeah so I'll try to
keep this to one minute
um I think one really important thing is
a lot of people have a question of this
being a state problem versus a
Manchester problem um I was one of the
protesters at the encampment occupation
um at 300 Chestnut Street and one thing
that was very clear there was that and I
have a fairly basic understanding of
this so maybe people can elaborate later
um a lot of the people who were there
are from all over the state because our
drug rehabilitation system specifically
fun people into Manchester and creates a
crisis there so this is something that
is a Statewide issue that kind of shows
up in these sort of specific focal
points um so I think study a Statewide
study is really warranted and another
thing a lot of the people that I met
there are really regular people and for
a lot of them they became houseless very
quickly and it was very apparent to me
that really any of us no matter what our
background is
are much closer than we think to being
houseless M I want SW I want to thank
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
excused call the next witness is
GRE
l
um hi everyone uh my name is Grace Lenny
I'm a student at New Market Junior
Senior High School um I'm here on
behalf of the New Hampshire High School
Democrats um the housing crisis in New
Hampshire is one that should concern
everyone and in New in November 2020 a
houseless encampment outside of the
Manchester Courthouse was raided by the
police department in frigid temperatures
people's belongings were destroyed and
some were forcefully removed by the
police housing has still not been
secured for them and the many other
houseless Granite Staters this
heartbreaking instance of police
brutality toward a group of people who
were trying to find a place to stay warm
and tense while temperatures dropped to
freezing overnight demonstrates a clear
need for the establishment of this
committee to examine law enforcement and
the criminal justice system's response
to houselessness in New Hampshire
New Hampshire should protect and find
housing for houseless people in the
state and establishing this committee is
an excellent first step in establishing
a more just system no one should have to
worry about violence from the law
enforcement especially not when they are
in a particularly vulnerable situation
and trying to find a place to shelter I
urge members of this committee to
support HB 286 and respectfully request
that no questions be asked afterwards
thank you so much for your
time
testimony the chair recognizes Sophia
chair for and I'm a member of the public
um three months ago I was at the
courthouse in Manchester New Hampshire
to protest the eviction of houseless
residents on government property it only
took me one night in the freezing cold
to see that we not only have a housing
crisis in New Hampshire but our
government seems IL equipped and
unprepared to tackle the issue when
residents ask for mental health and
substance use support they are met with
harassment and cruelty and when
residents ask for housing dignity
and respect they are met with violence
how can we address the problem if we
don't even have the lens to look at it I
want you to imagine being in sub-degree
weather in New Hampshire with nowhere to
go no warm bed to sleep in and ask
yourself how you would want to be
treated by your government slapping a
Band-Aid on the problem whenever New
Hampshire gets bad pressed is not
anywhere close to enough we need to
support our houseless neighbors
facilitated by re
research on the community's most
affected it doesn't take an expert to
see that we have a housing crisis in New
Hampshire and Bill 286 needs to be
official thank you Miss Ford your time
has
expired seeing no seeing No Hands raised
excused the chair now recognizes Rose
Harmon Now remind Miss Harmon that your
minute Rose Harman Mr chairman I don't
see that name let me double
chairman we'll Circle
back end Stephen
K recognized by the chair I will Mr K
minute again Mr chairman I don't see
Stephen maybe if they could raise their
hands Mr
chairman if there's any members of the
public who do wish to testify please
time Madison
Dean yes that's there hold on
thank you Mr
chairman hi my name is Madison Egan I'm
a resident of Manchester um I'm in
support of this bill over the years I've
seen several instances of harassment of
homeless folks but the worst of all I've
seen was during the eviction at the
courthouse last November I wish Witness
police officers slashing tents throwing
out people's belongings and laughing
while they did it it was clear they took
joy in this activity it was not a glum
occasion in which they simply had to do
their jobs but something they reveled in
I spoke to one resident who was still
asleep in their tent when they began
slashing the tents she could have been
injured it is abundantly clear that
there is a deep bias held towards the
homeless community and it absolutely has
you testimony seeing No Hands raised the
excused
Nate Stewart recognized by the chair
testified just as a reminder your
minute hi um that's not my name but I
was asked to unmute I just want to check
to make sure that I'm supposed to be
speaking it moved on me Mr chair I
apologize um I did click on the wrong
one
and with all du respect Miss Perez we do
uh have a practice of saving the lobby
forget so allow Nate Nate Nate Stewart
is
recognized
hello um so I was uh also at the uh Camp
uh last year uh and I saw firsthand how
the cops like uh didn't handle the
situation well at all uh it led to a lot
of harm against uh homeless folks uh and
I'm here to speak in favor of the bill
in part because I believe uh that uh
more uh needs to be done about how we
approach uh homelessness in this state I
know in my own hometown of Dober New
Hampshire our police chief has talked at
length about how he feels that uh the
cops are unequipped to deal with uh
homelessness and uh so like it's not
just a bunch of you know activists
calling for This research to be done
cops also uh feel like they're not
equipped uh to handle homelessness uh in
the same way that more uh restorative
methods would uh allow and a commission
would allow uh the state to look into
Alternatives that could work not just
for the state level state troopers but
for
expired seeing No Hands
raised witness is
excused back
to Stephen
ker you
still Mr chairman I do not see Steven
Harman I not seeing Mr uh U uh Rose
Harmon either Mr chairman this time the
Perez hi um thank you uh so my name is
Erica Perez I'm with New Hampshire youth
movement and I'm here to support um HB
286 um I'm also one of the organizers
who help prevent the eviction at the
encampment outside of the courthouse in
November um but I also personally every
Sunday um work at a free store that
gives supplies directly to the houseless
people I talk directly with them I
consider a lot of them my friends um
five of them have died since November um
and New Hampshire frankly is doing a
horrible job we don't have a plan to
deal with our homeless population we
treat them like pests we actively
incarcerate them we act we like kick
them out of shelters they have nowhere
to go they're kicked off of properties
like there is literally no place for
these people to go there are no real
resources for everybody there are
resources that come with conditions um
and that facility that you were talking
about representative B in Derry was um a
sober house where you weren't even
allowed to smoke cigarettes um but
essentially it's just a study committee
I don't understand why it's so hard to
want to investigate something that
clearly needs investigating we've been
talking all year about racial bias
training this is similar they are
treated less than because they have
nowhere to go there are biases that we
carry against houseless people I
actively help houseless people and I
also actively have to work on my biases
against H's people because we have been
raised to be taught that they are lazy
drugs M MZ your testimony is
expired you actually went about 30
seconds over the committ testimony so we
do have to
suspend representative Muse you're
recognized for a
question yes thank you thank you very
much um when it comes
to when it when it comes to the
relationship uh between how Hess people
and and the police I guess can you speak
a little more specifically to that and
the things that uh that you see is maybe
being things that a study committee
could
mute oh okay thank you sorry about that
um so for example um a lot of these
folks do have substance abuse issues and
instead um of taking them somewhere
where they can get help they are
immediately arrested if found with drugs
um I've spoken with people who have had
their IDs claimed by the police and not
given back so now that person lacks
identification
um they have their things
confiscated um and it just leads them to
have less and less um they are treated
like criminals because they have nowhere
to go um and it just creates this
repetitive cycle of um being
incarcerated having nothing and then
being incarcerated
sorry seeing No Hands raised the witness
is
you are there any members of the public
who are in attendance that wish to
testify that have not testified already
hand seeing No Hands raised at this at
this
time the chair will close the public
hearing on house bu 286
[Music]
and Mr chair for House Bill uh 286 we
had
245 people who signed in in support of
the bill we had one person who signed in
in
you
thank you again representative new at
this
time here is going to open the executive
125 it's the 17th day of February 2021
sorry thank
you the members there's been two
amendments just I want to clarify before
we begin the members at home do they
have a copy of each
Amendment no also apply to members in
the
[Music]
ises
no it's
online it's in the email you know the
State Rep email today I don't get that I
don't get any
of yeah Karen
Karen the I just forward uh
representative Roy's Amendment to the
committee
you bring me one
of oh maybe Chris can
help
abis
representative I don't get the
the folks online the
virtuals
they
they have
computer represent they
[Music]
have
I was on
so
real
maybe it's not even that has a massive
ink
Supply
at this time representative W is
03848 clarify that's
Amendment
0384 just explain what explain the
concept of the amendment I understand
that if this provision were to be
violated or Not by member of law
enforcement although there may be a
common law
claim there also may be issues
of um is whether immunity applies or not
I think the the concern here is I
think this expressed by repr n is it is
a problem when when a postest photo is
simply distributed without any any
reason that can ruin someone's life um
especially if that person is not
convicted of CRI what the amendment does
is it actually creates a private right
of action for the person who aggravated
by a law
enforcement's failure to comply with
this allow them to recover a statutory
fee or actual
damages in addition to the ob I will say
when it comes to proving your actual
damages you have to show some type of
loss or damage you know damage to one's
reputation is often hard to
prove of law s that SL it's hard to
prove how you've been injured by that
act so this puts some teeth behind the
enforcement side of it it also strikes
one sentence from the original bill but
the original Bill did allow the
photograph to be dispersed to the
alleged victim
in involving in the crime although I I I
allowing the victim to see the
photograph once you police dispers the
photograph now giv the photo to the
victim the victim could essentially then
put that photo on social media or online
so we really that could in many
circumstances defeat the purpose of what
this de I believe is trying to
accomplish it does not prevent the large
from showing the photo to the victim
they just cannot hand provide a digital
or physical copy
[Music]
in addition law enforcement is limited
only sharing it with other state or
local law enforce agencies that wouldn't
be not allowed to provide the federal
government then allow them to disperse
and I I will say I I support this I
support this bill not pass an amendment
you know a close friend of mine who I
grew up with was charged with a crime
about 10 years
ago and the reason why he was arrested
police were open about this that he
simply wouldn't uh subit to a DNA
test well he was arrested his photograph
was in the front page of
newspaper um since that time his life is
not the same to this day you Google's
name you'll see newspaper article and
his mugot in the article the police were
very Adam and celebrated they they talk
their their their guy
which this case didn't even proceed down
any meaningful discovery due to lack of
evidence and the victim recanted the
allegations as well
however it falls this day it's a very
serious charge and since that happened
he's been unable
to hold the steady JW because had one
season
photo so someone who I know very well I
grew up with has been
suffer as a result of law enforcement
doings there was no public interest in
disclosing the
photo and this is unfortunate happened
back in the day people were in the
courtroom you know they would have
wrong pass that in don't that so I'll be
we'll Now open up for
discussion representative
Newman thank you Mr chair I I have I
think a parliamentary inquiry uh there's
been some confusion about the Amendments
I understand that your amendment is 85h
and I believe that representative
Roy's amendment was 84 and the only
reason I mentioned the difference
between them his had a pen yours has a
penalty in it and his does not um is
understanding well I believe I'm just
basing it on I don't want to speak for
representative Roy but I recall his
testimony saying that put he didn't
believe that the penalty needed to be
put into the bill because it's a common
law cost of action although that may be
a correct
statement I still say there may be some
immunity issues there assuming there's
not you would prove your damages in
order to recover I will say it's very
difficult to do that but this allows is
for it's either actual damages if you're
able to prove it or you would you would
recover $10,000 plus your Le of that if
you're
aggravating
so represent new yes just to followup so
we are considering your Amendment 85h
and your amendment has has a f a penalty
in it is that
correct
you so the 10,000 who is the payback is
that something that's gonna end up
filtering down to the
city the way the way the EV is written
is the person so actually be the officer
whe that officer is identified or not is
a matter
of
only it's quite common that officers are
identified but at the same time there
are
exceptions but I will I'm just am I I'm
just say my opinion I would find it very
difficult to actually VI you have to
take the mugot and somehow public
dispers of that doubt me would be
very difficult and safe to
make
repres I don't see anything here that
talks to social
Med was that intentionally enough out of
it because remember that's where this is
the whole thought of this came from
social media this personing is
dispersing you know whether you give it
to a media or whether you publicize it
yourself on social media I think it
would apply both any type of public
disclosure of the post arrest
photo is whether it's on Facebook
Twitter or you give it to the the union
Le
does well dispersement is dispers I
don't believe it needs to say
specifically because then if you list
social media in newspaper Outlets you're
actually I could are limited know
they're walking around they posted you
know on a public billboard Town Hall you
that would be dispers in my op you don't
you don't necessarily list every form
dispers
something thank you representative
Marson thank you Mr
chairman I find the article three Roman
numeral 3 with the $110,000 liability
Plus cost and legal fees whichever is
greater but the point that there's that
penalty I find objectable I find that
I'm objecting to that part of this
amendment respectfully Mr
chairman um I think that this will cause
people
to if this would have happened file
lawsuits and it becomes a lot of that
kind
of tying up the court times ET ET Etc we
don't even have that right now but
because of the $110,000
amendment the only my only response that
would be
is if this is a law that we
pass it needs it needs to be an
enforceability side there's no penalty
behind what's what's the benefit of the
law I I think we we all agree in this
committee is the concept of this bill is
a
great great policy but if there's no
consequence for viol tree falls make any
noise
follow thank you could the amount be
lowered to Something in in the terms of
even
$1,000
well Beauty the beauty of our role here
that can be a different amendment I I
will say in basing one my
friend
anous $10,000 does not solve his
problem I'm just this should not happen
me that's just my that's just my take if
if we want if we are this policy is to
benefit protective to protect their
rights it needs to be a consequence of
my true thank you Mr chair
um I do have questions on on the
amendment but not now but a couple of
people have
mentioned that the the the
representative abis amendment is 30
85 that amendment that has been offered
we're discussing is amendment
3084 no 384 that's the yes 3085 doesn't
exist and hasn't been offed yet so I so
I just some people said referred to your
Amendment as 85 I just want to clear
that than 3084 is the one we're
discussing
correct representative right you are the
prime
sponsor am I allowed to talk about it
and exact yes I am
right okay thank you um
I I'm really conflicted I don't like who
I want to know who's responsible for
paying the 10,000 is it the police
department the police officer
personally um like what what is the
procedure there and do if we're going to
go that far and and we acknowledge that
mistakes can happen do we want to
include then like a first for second
offense or like say like you know this
is this you didn't take this
serious um do we want to work on this
more maybe have another amendment and
pull it for right
now repres in response to that I will
say if it's if this was that clearly
inadvertent
um by you know through a negligent act
by a police
officer my understanding is at least at
the state level that offut be identified
I I my understanding at the local level
it's common practice that if it's a
negligent act they would also be
identif followup chair if it's done
intentionally then then that's where the
issue of
identification
so oh
sorry meaning if it's an intentional
violation I'm
not as clear whether you'll be identifi
or not it's
simple incidentally you know they they
leave a
out lost
that's and this only applies again with
people can arrest
not I I just my concern is my taxpayers
paying for a mistake that a police
officer made or a police like some one
bad actor you know I don't I don't think
that's fair to my
constituents that's just one I want to
make sure
of right I'm a huge fan ofil that you
you put in I thank you for putting it in
I just want to make sure that they has
some enforceability behind it
consequences it's not
that repr news thank you Mr chair last
year when we heard testimony for this
bill um you know we actually heard some
different perspectives we we heard from
members of the news media uh who were
concerned I I believe we also heard uh
from some folks uh representing police I
think Captain Joe Ebert from the the
state police testified and one of the
things I think that he that he told us
so that I remember him telling us at the
time was that um violation of this could
also be a dis disciplinary issue that
would involve uh that could potentially
involve discipline from the police uh
standards uh and training Council um
like other violations uh that uh that
police are occas occasionally accused of
um I I guess my question is is the the
$10,000 uh civil damages for someone on
a policeman's salary seems to be very
very high um it would also seem to be a
motive something that would motivate me
as a police officer to uh not mess
around with this particular statute if I
knew that I could be dragged up before a
disciplinary hearing uh and potentially
be suspended or maybe even lose my
certification so I'm just wondering if
if uh if this is really necessary that I
question I I
will I mean necessary is a strong word I
still think if you have any law or
policy that has no enforce enforcement
mechanism behind it I understand that
maybe an internal discipline dising
action but I I think it's critical that
in order to deter this activity that we
deter other activities with penalties of
crime there needs to be some some
provision here because people are
injured and damaged by this they have
and they can be they were serious about
stopping it my belief you need to have
uh thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
oppose this amendment um I think the
penalty uh makes uh the law a little
murky I think more important is the
policy and I think that if we uh include
the penalty into this uh Bill uh it's
very likely uh to uh go down in
flames
representative B thank you Mr chairman
uh Mr chairman I support the amendment
that's brought forward the 0384
amendment because I like the the small
penalty there um because there has to be
deterrence you know because in my eyes
you know it's extremely rare that I
think they do that but you know if they
arrest somebody a charge and the person
being arrested is not a happy person and
causes trouble you know I think
sometimes they throw it out on social
media to say okay here you go they throw
it out there um this will slow that
behavior down because our police cannot
be the judge and jury and this will slow
that down to uh to embarrass him or her
uh so I'm I'm I'm in support of it and I
don't think this is going to clog the
court system you know as my friend uh
representative said from Manchester that
it would and the reason I feel that is I
don't think this happens a lot so the
rare times it does happen it gives the
person that's just being charged an
Avenue to recover some cost that he's
incurring uh during that time and then
later all the charges are probably
dropped um thank you Mr chairman I'll be
supporting
it true thank you Mr chair
um I have questions on the amendment by
the way I read the amendment basically
the amendment becomes the
bill um and so I'm trying to decide
trying to see where the changes
are true so line on the original Bill
lines 12 to
15 that one
sentence was changed and then
bision was add otherwise the rest of the
same throw the hands up the all the
amend
camera Vice chairman
wilch yes representative Burke yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative
Marston
no the clerk votes
yes representative harrith G
no Representative panellus
no Representative
o'n
no Representative bordon
no representative muse
no representative Newman
voted
no representative Conley
no representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley
yes
by a vote of 10 y 11 the amendment fails
f n you recogniz can I make a motion to
bring forth the other Amendment from
representative
Roy it it's right now the
hell you recognize to discuss the motion
about to
pass uh I'm not quite sure of the
procedure on this on this particular
session um I think that we can offer a
at this point um and I would like to do
off Mr chairman a point of
recognized point of order my point of
order is that the last amendment to my
best of my knowledge passed is that
correct no no not no okay I withdraw I
withdraw
that is not a point of order that is a
question a point of order is when you're
questioning whether the chair of the
committee is following parliamentary
procedure or the rules correctly if that
is a what a point of order if you have a
question to the chair please raise your
hand you be you will be recognized for a
question a point of order the chair must
interrupt everything that's going on and
recognize the point of order you're out
of order your point of order was out of
order
thank you for that information Mr
chairman uh in the future I'll try and
raise it as a parliamentary inquiry I
think that may
[Music]
be question so are you saying that we we
can't do another
pass only Committee
[Music]
Member right and I think that's what a
a
so you're asking representative want to
other I think he has a totally different
Amendment represent bney do you have an
amendment that is you wish to offer
that's that's ready to be offer yes I
do and is that the can you read the
number of
that uh this is amendment offered by
representative Roy um 2021 - 385 H uh I
have forwarded a copy to uh the
committee it basically
clarifies uh uh the process and it does
not offer a uh a penalty you wish to off
you wish to offer that amend yes I
do you recognize offer the
second I'll second
second repres you
seconded that's correct should speak on
the
amendment um I really basically have
nothing more to offer than what
representative Roy uh provided in his
testimony um uh it is uh it does improve
the uh bill as originally presented and
um I encourage you to adopt the
amended
repres U question for the chair and
maybe I'm a little confused I thought
that the only amendments that could be
presented to the committee has to be
coming from a Committee Member not uh
from a other representative outside the
committee so you are correct what
although the the
amendment was brought by representative
Roy I believe representative bour has
now offered the amendment so the the
amendment is still being offered by
member of the
committee and then that was second I
believe that that that is an
order I I will say it is my opinion
better practice to have a member of the
committee's name on the amendment but I
don't believe that's necessary
mist my understanding I may be wrong
name name is not
number
Red I was suggest recess this
[Music]
until I would agree with the
representative
Welch what I'll do is get clarification
on
that
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr chairman in
the 11 years I've been here uh we have
agreed as a committee that we like let's
say if this amendment passed um I have
seen this in the past and we have agreed
okay we will make sure that the name is
changed and as long as the name is Chang
changed um to a Committee Member we're
going to adopt the committee or or the
amendment or deny the amendment on
depending on how the vote is we have
done that in the past to to save
time what I'm gonna recommend we do
because we are running we do have a
public hearing that we should start
representative B while we're in that
public hearing though I I you do have a
job assignment I would recommend you add
your name to that Amendment so we can
make this question
uh so what I would recommend is just
asking legislative service to add
whether it's a new number or not add
your name to that Amendment and we'll
reopen this executive session today and
then also if you don't mind for the
amend to committee assistant to print
out members in the room we have three
members in the room physically with
computer
online so this at this time we're gonna
the executive
session on House Bill 125 will be in
recess and this time we're going to open
the the chair will open the public
485 I'll be recognized very familiar
representa would love to talk earlier
repres
Roy off his and repres Roy despite
speak
there representative Ro you
unmuted
us keeps going back to mute and
us
he says he can hear you we can't hear
you okay how about that try that
representative
Roy no we can't hear you oh he's unmuted
again he's got a hand
up
I could promote him to panelist maybe
hits his
software yeah you should just do that
and then you can remove it after he's
done giving
Roy no all right representative
Roy representative Roy a
difficulties Str to in this room
uh would represent representative KN or
represent I believe inter
our co-sponsors with would one of you
mind just introducing the bill so we can
call other Witnesses just to
get it while as soon as we get yourself
you yeah
testimony for this is be lied two
minutes per witness and questions will
be
limited
raised um Mr chairman I just wanted to
let you know I am not a co-sponsor on
this
bill oh excuse
me
representa would you mind this is
representative Roy can you hear me oh
here he is just in time you saved
me yeah I apologize I had to step on my
anymore okay so uh let me just start
again um thank you for hearing to spill
I apologize for the uh the morass I
launched you in on the last bill with my
Amendment but this bill um this bill
that we're going to talk about now is
regarding um consensual searches and I'd
like to stop by saying this is a this is
a conservative bill this is a liberal
bill this is a Libertarian bill this is
a educational bill um when most of us
were growing up we had a class in school
called Civics and in our civics class
they taught you how to interact with law
enforcement what your rights were and
things of this nature um I I I feel that
that's not quite as uh robust as it once
was so what this bill would do similar
to but different than the Miranda
warnings police officers give this would
be a police officer in New Hampshire if
they were so inclined to search a
vehicle they would ask permission to
search the vehicle and when they do they
would inform the citizen that they have
the right to decline such a search um
now it it may sound complicated it's
very simple I'll walk you through an
example um a police officer a vehicle
leaving an area where there's no drug
activity um he knows the owner of the
vehicle has a history of drug
convictions but he doesn't see enough to
establish probable cause probable cause
he would not need consent to search the
vehicle so he does a a he follows the
vehicle has a tail light out he speeds
he does a a stop and addresses and
speaks to the operator and asked the
operator how he's doing um what you been
up to tonight I saw you at that
place um you have any drugs in the
vehicle or anything I need to worry
about and the person would most likely
say no and at this point the officer say
well then you wouldn't mindifi take a
look would you now the average citizen
when they're asked that question by a
police officer feels intimidated they
feel like well if I say no I'm G look
guilty all the officer has to do at that
point is to say well you don't mind if I
take a look do you I mean you don't have
to let me look you have the right not to
but that's all that's all we're asking
that they inform the citizen that they
have a right to decline the search um so
as I said at the beginning this is an
education bill um Civics all we're doing
is making the police let people know
they have the right to refuse the
search and I'd be happy to take any
that representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question in the case that you just
described where the citizen um where the
police officer if he did have probable
enough to establish probable
cause how would that how would that
transaction transpire
differently oh thank you for the
question representative police officer
has probable cause to search a vehicle
um or a person he can stop he can
effectuate the Stop and he he's allowed
with probable cause for for a vehicle
there's two ways it can go um and and
again I've been out of the out of the uh
out of the game for quite some time but
my recollection is because a vehicle is
high inherently mobile and evidence
could be moved the op officer can search
the vehicle using probable cause that he
can articulate he has or he can seize
the vehicle until he can obtain a search
warrant from a
judge um so let's say in that situation
he went with a search warrant option he
has probable cause he could seize the
vehicle remove the operator from the
vehicle the operator of course is free
to leave unless he's seized as well um
and the ve they would obtain a search
warrant and search the vehicle or he
could use probable cause to search a
warrantless search of the vehicle um
many departments May opt for the the uh
the warrant aspect it just depends on
the
situation do
it just quick followup so then I mean
we're talking about giving information
to the citizen he probably would tell
would tell him that at the point that he
is taking whatever action he takes it is
not consensual because people by then
would everyone would know based on this
law that you have the right to refuse
non consensual
sirar is that correct um I I would say
in my experience no um it would not be
correct um you'd be shocked at how many
people um tell you now that you can
search the car even though they don't
they AR warned that they have a right
not to um people know there's drugs in
the car know the police are going to
search it and the police off officer
asks MCH your vehicle even though he
didn't say you have a right to say no
implied in the question may I search is
uh is the ability to say no to that
search but they say yes anyway hoping
that if they say yes the search won't
happen or the police officer won't find
it um what have you so I I would say
know that most people still will not say
no most people don't I mean you can say
no to a field sobriety test but people
take it anyway knowing they're going to
fail because they feel like if they say
no it makes them look guilty it's it's
an interesting uh study in in
Psychology thank
you
represent I mean sorry representative
news thank you um I just had one
question I I know that this bill has
been compared in some ways uh to the
Miranda warning um and the language for
the Miranda warning is is fairly uh
fairly formal um I'm not a police
officer but it seems like every police
drama I've ever seen on TV uh they say
it pretty much the same way and and I'm
curious if you think that there there
may be some room for some ambiguity or
for
misinterpretation if this uh isn't
communicated uh to people in a way that
maybe is a little more standard and
formal thank you for the question
representative M and it's possible that
maybe the difference between Miranda and
Nessa is a couple things Miranda
requires in uh custodial interrogation
that means that the person has to be in
custody so a lot of clever police
officers will conduct investigations in
a public public place so the person can
never claim their in custody and don't
require the Miranda warnings the Miranda
warnings themselves um came from the
Supreme Court um and they said what had
to be had to be um had to be said and
implied in the warnings this coming from
the legislature is a lot different um so
we we're free to to say you know we C we
could spell out exactly what they have
to say we could create a form they have
to use but I don't want to hamstring the
police entirely because a lot of good
police work does come from gut instincts
and them being able to ask a citizen do
you mind if I search and them saying no
you know I don't think so or you know as
long as the police officer tells them
they don't have to I think that we've
we've sered Our obligation to our
citizens while at the same time not
hamstering our police officers from
being able to do good investigative
you
representative green thank you Mr
chairman thank you m representative Roy
if the person consented to have their
car
inspected uh how far would the officer
go uh before he started dismantling
everything in the
car um that's a good question I would I
would suggest um based on common sense a
road deid stop a consensual search isn't
going to get into taking taking um
taking apart the vehicle um they
wouldn't have the ability the tools or
whatever to do that um again there there
is some some ambiguity net the citizens
free to stop the search at any time and
say you know what I withdraw my consent
when they start pulling the seat
cushions off if if that's the issue um
it it's really between the citizen and
the uh police officer how far that the
citizens W willing to let it
you represent thank you for your
testimony the chair uh would ask a
question of the witness and I want to
thank you in advance for taking my
question I I I I support the concept of
this bill what I what I would ask in a
circumstance where an officer fails to
comply with the
requirements of this of this bill of
this
law would you support an amendment that
would make basically as a matter of law
make that search be done without consent
unconsented
search I would I just I would be
interested in the mechanism you would
use to do that I mean currently there
are consensual searches happening all
around the country and questions of
credibility as you well know come up in
court as to if a if a citizen says hey I
did not consent to that search and the
police officer say yes I did it comes
down to a question of credibility I I
would think the only way to alleviate
that would be some type of a assigned
document to allow the search the only
concern I have with that is once you get
people signing things um it it it raises
the bar so high that most people are are
you're going to you're going to
hamstring the police from the ability to
to use this consensual Search tool um
once you start producing documents to be
signed it's kind of like the um it's
kind of like with the with the
breathalizer you know when you get to
that part portion of it and it it gets
it gets a it gets official that's when
you get more refusals than you do for
field sobriety test for example and a
citizen can refuse both of those but
generally they take the field sobriety
test but the breath liiz is where
they'll they'll suddenly wake up and
realize what's happening so I I'm trying
to walk as fine a line as possible by
not hamstringing the police but yet
notifying them so I mean I would be open
to any
Amendment um short of making something
where the citizens had to sign
permission because I feel like that
would definitely complicate the police
more my question representative
n thank you chair thanks for taking my
question representative do you think
based off of what you just said we're
discussing how to prove if your rights
have actually been given to you do you
think in this instance it would be
beneficial for our state to have body
cams on our police
officers um well I I'm not sure how how
gerain it is to to the bill but yes I've
always been a proponent of body camps
they they're good for the police and for
the citizens um but yeah yeah I I
definitely would think that it would be
helpful because that would take away any
questions of whether or not consent was
given or not
you representative true thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
representative
uh I didn't quite understand uh I know
we're talking about things that don't
exist yet but you I think you said you
were against having the the police have
the uh people sign a form because it
might hamstring the police but isn't the
whole purpose of your bill to make sure
people are fully informed that that they
do not have to allow the police to
search their their
guard than super question representative
Tru and and and I agree that there is um
there there is some inherent conflict in
the two I mean I guess I would say that
you know we we could also say that they
have a right to an attorney before they
speak to police officer at all and I'm
sure the chairman would tell you that
they would say don't talk to them about
anything so we have to make an
assumption that that citizens are are
once they've been warned they don't have
to submit to the search are are wise
enough to make their own decision um
whether or not they wish to go further
with that um
but as with Miranda um I don't I'm not
sure it's required but a lot of places
use a Miranda card where they ask the
the person to sign their rights um and
it's in a much more solemn and
controlled setting on the side of a
highway at nighttime asking someone to
sign a document um I I just feel it gets
very complicated it it
um you could almost get into whether or
not you know was he did he feel like he
had to sign the document so he could
leave so then the document has to have a
warning that you don't have to sign this
document it just it creates a whole
legal legal morass that we could get
pulled into um while it get decided in
the court whereas if we simply say the
police officer has to verbally warn the
person they have a right to refuse the
search um I think it it's much less um
complicated but I do agree with you
representative truid when balancing
rights like this it's a it's often a
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank you for your
you
chairman whoops I'm in the wrong screen
sorry uh can people hear me now and
Professor we we're limiting testimony to
two minutes per per witness I'm just
going to get wound up at two minute time
but uh I I will abide by that thank you
uh Mr chair um my name's Albert Sher
often known as was um I've been a a
professor at UNH law for 27 or 28 years
prior to that uh I was a public defender
in New Hampshire for 30 years so I've
been involved in the criminal justice
system in New Hampshire for about 40
years now I teach in the area relevant
to this uh uh uh HB 485 I teach in the
area of criminal procedure which this
directly involves um let me make uh and
one more thing uh the opinions I
expressed today are my opinions and not
the opinions of unh law or UNH proper U
so this is what I would call Miranda
light uh it doesn't have the intense
formality that uh Miranda does uh given
the circumstances though stressful for
for example the driver of a car very
stressful it it it's not compared to the
stress that one under goes when one is
undergoing con uh custodial
interrogation the import it's important
to understand this bill does not create
any new rights the right to refuse to
consent to a search is you have that
constitutional right all this bill does
is notify the uh the individual that
they have that right uh I think the huge
majority of individuals don't know they
have that right uh I think uh
representative Roy is right that most
people will still go ahead and consent
there's a study done as my written
testimony reflects that a a a a mock you
know
situation uh unfortunately by academics
don't hold that against the study uh but
they they tried out uh whether people
would be more inclined to refuse to
consent if they were told they had the
right to consent and the studies s found
no difference in the rate at which
people refused to consent more
fundamentally Miranda itself a study was
done in 1999 that showed that after
people are read their their Miranda
rights almost 90% of them wave their
Miranda rights so this is not going to
be a big
imposition uh there are six states
currently who have either by Court uh uh
Court decision or by Statute have a
provision similar to this uh there are
any number of municipalities in North
Carolina uh in Kentucky the state of
Mississippi the state of Arkansas uh
their Supreme Courts have both found
that there is a right that they have to
be told that there's a right to refuse
the uh the town of Wentworth New
Hampshire has in their consent search
form uh language that says you have a
right to refuse
here you go 4 25 seconds over the time
Li I will uh silence myself and uh
answer any questions that anyone
has you got lucky Mr she thank you
fortunately I'm remote so you can't
physically punish
me representative G Rec for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um you said there's a town
that they actually have a
form that yeah um most uh thank you for
your question representative G most uh
most towns in virtually every town in
New Hampshire has a consent to search
form um uh so it's not unusual that the
a town has a form that has a consent to
search on it
uh many of them do not include a right
to refuse to consent in that form but
that the town of Wentworth New Hampshire
does um and uh the the Bureau of Highway
Patrol enforcement in New Hampshire uh
they also inform individuals of their
right to refuse so uh it's not going to
be a big change for police departments
in New Hampshire and in fact well I'll
leave it at that
represent G recognize for a follow off
question okay so is this form something
that um the person that stopped signs or
or it's just read to them
and it depends on the police
department um but you know the the the
Attorney General's office law
enforcement manual makes it clear that
although not required at this point to
inform somebody of their right to refuse
uh let me read what they say in the law
enforcement manual police officers are
not obligated to inform people that they
have a right to refuse consent however
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
stated that it is good policy to do so
and in some situations such as a knock
and talk procedure the court is
considered requiring it as a
prerequisite to valid consent that a
person was informed of the right to
refuse before giving consent would be an
important factor in in a favor of a
finding of
voluntariness so the you know the the
more documentation the the better um I
appreciate Representatives Roy's
comments um about uh documentation being
perhaps being an impediment and I
understand that but certainly the the
Attorney General's law enforcement man
manual is very encouraging if police uh
of of informing people of their right to
refuse and you know it would not be a
big burden on any Police Department to
change uh to create a form or to change
refuse see seeing No Hands
raised WIC I thank you your
Joseph
Eber now just as a reminder your
minutes hi good afternoon everyone my
name is Joe Ebert it's EBT I'm a captain
with the New Hampshire State Police
overseeing the Investigative Services
Bureau um so uh today I I did want to uh
recognize um the testimony that I
listened to from representative Roy I
think this is a very reasonable Bill uh
to to make that notification to persons
uh is something that the state police uh
would encourage and and would support uh
there is one portion of the bill that I
had concern with uh that the division of
State Police had concerned with as we
reviewed it and that is the um uh
section that talks about omitting uh
that the person refused a consent search
within an affidavit that's submitted
later for um for a search warrant so the
concern we have there is one really just
of uh uh more procedure than anything I
understand what the representative or I
think I understand what the
representative was getting at there that
it shouldn't be used as a basis to build
uh probable cause however it is a fact
that U took place and I would be
concerned if we were omitting any facts
uh as we were submitting an affidavit to
the uh to the judge I think it's
incumbent upon the judge to uh give
weight to that whatever fact is laid
before them uh so that's that's really
the only issue that uh that we had that
we wanted to bring to the um to the
conscience of the committee and and with
that I'm happy to answer any questions
[Music]
them seeing No Hands raised uh Mr E
thank you for your testimony thank you
very
Davis can your
testimon two minutes yes thank you um so
my name is Melissa Davis and I'm here to
testify on the behalf of the board of
directors for the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
in support of this bill I've practiced
uh criminal defense law in New Hampshire
for over 15 years first as a public
defender and I'm now the director of the
criminal P Practice Clinic at UNH
Franklin Pierce School of Law the
statements I make today are in my own
capacity and and not representative of
the UNH law school or un itself but I am
speaking for the NHC CDL board um you
know I do agree with that with what
others have said today and that
essentially this um Bill does not change
the law it does not um you know give
anyone more rights than they already
have it simply informs them of the
rights that they have um and lets them
know that um should they choose to
exercise those rights um that they will
that that the choice to exercise those
rights is not going to be used against
them um you know I did submit written
testimony on this in my experience is
that you know anyone um in this
situation you me um anyone uh who is
pulled over on the side of the road and
you confronting a police officer um who
was perhaps looking into whether or not
they did something wrong um is put in a
position of sort of um being kind of
under the microscope under under sort of
the gun at that point to feel that you
know they need to you know cooperate and
comply otherwise um you know something
bad might happen to them and that
includes making the choice to exercise
their rights but you know this bill
would interrupt that and tell them that
you know if they were uh that one it
would inform them of their right and two
it would tell them that you know if they
um chose to exercise that right that it
would not be um used against them and
would allow them to make a free choice
in that moment um you know I think right
now I can tell you I think someone
raised a question earlier about you know
Miranda rights and obviously that is a
more formal process but once advised of
those rights given the opportunity to um
review them think about them I would say
you know it is most um lawyers would
tell you that the majority of people are
signing you know they're making these
choices but they're doing it in this
moment that is you know kind of free
from uh kind of the pressure of
answering you know in that moment and
instead being able to reflect upon their
rights um as read to them um being advis
that they have agency and choice in that
moment um I think it it would probably
result in a similar situation on the
side of the road um with these drivers
but what this would do is change the
nature into the of that encounter into
one where the individual you know can
make an informed choice and you know
should they refuse to grant that consent
the officer is still free to use the
evidence that he had attorney Davis we
do have limit t two minutes you almost
minutes so I apologize sorry I wasn't
with the stopwatch but thank you for
letting me know it's so problem the CH I
want thank you for your testimony I I do
also have a question I would thank you
in advance for taking my
question I guess I I support the policy
that
hb45 was
created what I what I'm wondering is in
a circumstance where an officer didn't
comply with the uh this poliy that would
be they didn't advise an individual of
their
right um to not that they don't have to
consent of
search what what would be the
consequence of that search I understand
if assuming there was no other cost
basis for
search so you're saying that if if the
officer failed to abide by this law
should it go into effect and so failed
to uh advise an individual of their
right to refuse used to consent what
would the consequence be
yes I think under the bill is
is currently written I don't think
there's anything in in this bill itself
that um gives consequence to that I
think in the courtroom um the argument
over whether or not consent was
voluntarily given at that point would
begin and um you know it it would sort
of uh fall to I think the uh parties to
argue whether that consent was freely
given in that moment um and what the
encounter
than seeing No Hands
you
can you can you hear
me we uh although it's me really it's a
reminder myself that the test two
minutes but the last two witnesses went
over too so I will allow you two and a
half minutes thank you thank you chair I
appreciate that um thank you chair and
committee for taking my testimony my
name is Joseph laskas I am testifying
today on behalf of the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire and we
are in support of this
legislation um the first thing that I
just wanted to start off uh saying about
this bill is that this bill is not going
to create a new right um all it does is
just requires that police officers
inform individuals of a pre-existing
right and it's it's funny because when I
first heard about this bill I did a
quick poll of um the individuals I knew
whether or not they they knew that they
had the right to uh to refuse a search
and they did not most people did not
know and I you know I don't know you
know the majority of New Hampshire but
you know pretty much everyone I knew
didn't know this and the the other thing
is that individuals uh one person
responded to me that they had a
situation where um they were pulled over
and the the police officer thought that
they were doing something wrong and and
told them you know well if you have
nothing to hide then then you should let
me search your car your vehicle and they
did because they felt like I need to
prove that I have nothing to hide and
that um I I I think that's the problem
and that's what this bill is is aimed at
correcting is just making sure that
individuals are informed about their
rights and that they are making an
informed um decision and and like repres
represenative Roy said I don't think it
could have been said better this is
really just about Civics here this is
about just making sure that people know
their right here in the grit state that
they have a um you know that that
informed consent and that they're giving
it and that they have a positive
interaction with law enforcement so it's
for these reasons and those that have
been stated before um that we strongly
support this legislation and hope that
this committee votes ought to pass on
this I am happy to take any questions
under two and a half minutes I would say
seconds 30
seconds representative true thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um realizing that if if it's uh if the
officer has a probable cause none of
this matters but the way the bill is
written do you see any with it just
falling back to he said she said the
officer searches your car and you say
well I never gave him permission and he
says yeah yeah he did give me permission
you see a problem with that I do uh I do
see a problem with that um as someone
who has gone through the criminal
justice system um and I've seen many
individuals go through the criminal
justice system it does it does create a
frustration um on the individual's part
when they feel as if well when they find
out that they have had a right that was
never um exercised or that they did
exercise a right and it's not being
recognized that that can provide um
complications especially when trying to
sort out a case um in the courts uh but
as we heard that the courts would um you
know the judge would then start making
that determination um then but that can
problem
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
testimony are there any members of the
public who wish to testify that are
present that have not already
hand
hello uh can you hear me yes thank you
so much so uh again my name is
as um I'm calling in because I support
this bill uh because police have an a
certain kind of authority within our
community um people will oftentimes just
do as they're told and so if they're
even being asked a question uh it'll be
thought of as mandatory versus the
choice that they can actually refuse um
I can tell as well as someone who's done
several know your rights presentations
in the Upper Valley um with a lawyer
most people had no idea that they can
actually U refuse a search um so why is
this important because studies show over
and over again that people get racially
profiled who've done nothing that
warrants a search so for example um if
an officer stops someone for a traffic
violation um but because of what we know
happens often times to people of at a
much higher rate they're also asked if a
police officer can search their car um
so yeah this is not going to stop racial
profiling I'm not going to say that um
this will end it but it can and it does
help people know that they at least have
a choice versus they must just accept so
this is a step in the right direction in
my opinion um yeah and so I think this
communities
testimony thank you see seeing No Hands
excused Anthony
haris hello how everybody doing this
afternoon my name is Anthony Harris um
um I support this bill I feel like um
you know there was once upon a time um I
wrote on the other side of the law you
know that was my past life and this uh
I've gotten pulled over a couple of
times
and I didn't know that it was my right
um to deny uh consensual um a search of
my vehicle and um the last time I was I
was pulled over because my plates um my
plates were out of date so he had a
right to pull me over um and then he
asked me if I had any drugs and I told
him no and he he asked me to search my
vehicle and I said for what because I
don't have any drugs you pulled me over
for this for this particular reason and
he told me um that if I didn't let him
search my car he was just going to call
another officer a k9 officer and um have
the dogs come around my car there was um
he had no reason to do that and I feel
like um um there's a lot of racial
profiling and as as um esma just said
you know I don't feel like this bill
will stop the um the the racial
profiling but at least it gives it gives
the citizens and the community um an
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
excuse say it again is there's any
members of the public who wish testify
that have not testified
hand seeing No Hands raised at this time
we will close the public hearing House
Bill
45 at this time we will be we will be in
recess to
[Music]
1:00 Mr chair on uh on House Bill 485 we
had 96 people signing in in support uh
neutral let let's make that in recess
to yes we're in recess to one o' thank
you
representative
anything I time to eat 12
exact
e
[Music]
we
have
[Music]
myair
the people
working can you hear
me
right this time
chair we're GNA open we're open the
executive session on House Bill
p.m. the chairs recogniz represent G
um I move octop pass for House Bill
286 um it is definitely needed in the
state of New
your that is seconded by representative
Welles to speak your oh sorry I just
wanted to say that um first of all I
want to uh thank representative K Knight
for bringing it forth and um I truly
believe that this might help some of the
conditions that we have with the
homeless and as everybody know
especially the larger cities really do
have a
problem so hopefully a committee can
come up with some data or some
information that can help the state
issues
i' like to make a comment
I I told you about 10 years
ago I spent two years my company sent me
out to C years and and that was a
beautiful city a little bit of home but
it was really
a there's a there's
a out now it's
actually TV station I'm sorry we can't
hear you I said there's there's a
there's a movie out now put out by a
reporters on the local TV station in
Seattle it's called Seattle is dying and
they analyzed the
situation and they looked at it in other
states too also like Rhode Island the
problem with homelessness is
not yeah wo is me the problem is drugs
and they they they looked at all the
people who were really homeless and they
have a real problem out there and if
we're not careful we're gonna have the
same problem here and it was
almost to a person they they found drugs
was the issue and that's what needs to
be addressed
we've got same problem in Franklin our
police are fairly gentle with them I
would say
but most of them they offer them a place
to stay it's a place to stay as rules
you can't bring
Contraband and they don't want to
go how do you cure that it's not a
police problem it's really the
individual problem and it
drugs
represent
P yeah thank you Mr chairman I would
like to see this bill passed I don't
think it's a police job to do it but you
know we have so many ordinance in these
towns and cities that won't even let
little houses into them or any place for
these people to go and they don't all
have
drugs they paid low wages and once they
lose a week work week of work they're
out on the street so we need to do
you
representative' yes can you hear
me we can hear you okay my only question
I guess would be maybe for the sponsor
or or somebody else but uh the
realistically the November reporting
back to the uh everybody is that going
to after this has passed going to be a
happen represent n you want to respond
to
that um I mean I hope that we can put
together a team of experienced
professionals and police officers
anybody that's willing to be a part of
this discussion and come up with
something
um it's our responsibility to at least
try so I'm going to do my best to meet
any deadlines that we have does that
question for me it basically didn't um
my question basically is you know I've
been in the legislature enough to know
that things don't happen very quickly
and to have a November reporting that
compiles all the information to report
back to these uh bodies uh doesn't seem
me thank you chair I want to thank
representative Klein Knight for bringing
this um Bill forward I think this is
definitely something that's needed um
within our communities and I will be
bill represent Maron thank you Mr
chairman I several points to bring out
one is the fact that they want to use
the whole state for this not just
Manchester this doesn't this bill does
not refer the homelessness in Manchester
not does it refer to the homelessness in
Nashville or in Franklin or in
Dairy and so this is a wide open thing
and like other representative pointed
out trying to get some resolve back by
November 1 I don't think it's possible
and last but not least I question to my
esteemed Vice chair is this a 28a
issue
no than just just to address that and I
understand the concern that maybe the
issue of homelessness is not a problem
on a Statewide basis but what I
understand from the testimony that the
some of the issues that came up involve
State Police so I think it's it's wise
to
approve involve State Police the
argument could be made that is issue
State
concern Manchester biger highly pop are
say although I don't I may not ha from
those districts I still think it's it's
relevant
to state to look at at whole just my
thought I don't think it's it's wrong to
the whole I think going be looking the
North
Country pop
areas I hope the commission uses uses
the little time that they have to meet
up follow thank you Mr chairman uh I
just wanted to make a statement that I
should have made my first time I will be
voting no on this bill based on what I
stated
be leave it leave it for discussion
representative
I just like to say that I I will be
supporting this bill and one of the
reasons I like this bill is because the
focus of this study uh isn't looking at
the entire universe of homelessness in
the state it really focuses on the
relationship between uh between law
enforcement and people who are homeless
um I think that over the last uh few
months we've seen with a pandemic that
that that's actually been a real pain
point
and I mean in my experience study
committees that tend to be more
effective um have that kind of narrower
Focus uh I think it's what what a
committee like that will do is it will
definitely raise some some larger issues
uh that also need to be addressed that's
part of the part of the deal but uh the
other part of it is is um it's not
having served on three St study
committees um one of the things uh you
know that I just want to say is that a
November deadline is pretty common and
one of the reasons why we have a
November deadline is so we can draft
legislation uh in the next session if we
think any legislation is needed to
implement some of the recommendations
that we might have so a good example of
that was the work that we did uh on the
the bail Commissioners uh pay issue so
that's that's an example of how the
process uh can not only happen quickly
but can result in legislation that we
can actually you know get past so you
know to me this just seems to be a good
way uh to give us uh something to grab
on to that will allow us to start to
deal with this problem U as a body and
it it's definitely something that we
need to do we have a we have a housing
crisis in the state um we have an
economy that could be doing better
that's not necessarily working for a lot
of people at the lower end of the scale
and uh this is just something that uh
strikes me is is good public policy um
that we can nudge forward with this Bill
thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chair
um this committee is pretty narrow
the the comme would be charged with uh
to study the response of law enforcement
to
homelessness
um law enforcement doesn't really have
much to do with homelessness or housing
shortage and uh it also has the charge
of uh the study the response of the
criminal justice system to
homelessness Criminal Justice System
doesn't have that much to
do with the housing
shortage I heard testimony that people
are looking for data uh about the mental
health issues and drug issues and
Rehabilitation all of which has nothing
to do with what this committee is
charged with is charged with the
committee to study how the law
enforcement uh responds to homelessness
and how the courts respond respond to
homelessness I think on this bill I'll
uh I'll be supporting Mr M
chair thank you represent true so I
understand the way the commission narrow
focus of the commission my understanding
is the commission is going to focus on
instead law enforcement response to it
when law it's when law enforcement is
dealing with any police Rel involv
that's just my understanding of what
commission
study and then the criminal justice
system is the same way there are which
I'm not really sure how that I'm not
sure how that
part to it based on the testimony I
understand they could they could easily
over but I think at this point
everyone's had a chance to speak so we
can can put the matter of
question
uh the motion is about to
pass uh the RO support please say yay if
nay Vice chairman Welch
all representative
B yes representative
Hopper
green which bill is this that we voting
up committee to study response to law
enforcement
yes representative Wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative true
n representative Pratt yes
Representative morston
no the clerk votes yes yes
representative Harriet GA
panus
yes representative
o'n
bordon
yes representative Muse
yes representative
Newman yes
representative
bden yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative
Bradley
yes chairman abis chair votes
yes chairman V
[Music]
19 by a vote of 19 Y and two NS the
pass Mr chairman yes you recognize thank
you Mr chairman um I would as long as
there's no Minority Report I would
recommend a consent calendar for
this and that
is
Wallace No
obje
weent thank you Mr
chairman representa preparing the
majority
report sure or would it be night
night it is her
bill
me
cl close the executive session
286 yes thank you for recognizing me I
didn't understand what representative
Bert said and what that discussion was
about because there was only two um days
and 19 y the the off task motion this
can be put on the consent C rather than
having an individual uh be heard
individually it can be put on consent
and pass as part of consent
count so he's asked this this
bill be on the
consent it's on
consent I remember when I heard this
that consent on the consent calendar was
unanimous doesn't have
have up to
two objections still have
on representative Mar thank you Mr
chairman whether we whether you change
it here within committee or I have to go
to the to the clerk's office and ask has
to be taken off consent and go on
regular calendar that will happen so I
guess what I'm asking is well when
representative B moves to put on
consent that was you can still anyone
can take it off consent anytime they
want supported off the test so but
that's the time when going forward you
want to raise that that
objection ionically represent
represent Mar the reason I didn't object
was I didn't hear what he was saying on
comprehending I would have objected if I
had heard what he was asking for to be
on the consent
calendar listen my understanding is that
we have L something he can still be
taken off in sense and and we're not
ignoring what you have to say and
clearly you have an objection you sound
very confident that you're going to move
from so there's nothing wrong with you
doing that and it's any member of the
body to
hour uh thank you Mr chairman um if you
don't mind me adding the only reason to
remove it off consent is if you're going
to have a floor fight on this particular
bill um you know in the 11 years I've
been here I've only removed one bill off
consent and but that's the purpose to do
it if there's not going to be a floor
fight usually it's better just to leave
it on consent and let it go through and
then that way you know just saves a lot
of time but if there's going to be a
floor fight then you need to put in a
minority
board is that bill that
[Music]
I
noes makes yes at this time we will
uh the ex session on hit
repres I was inquiring so it's going to
be off the consent calendar because
objection well my understanding is
representative Marson is going to take
it off the consent calendar is not
agreeing to being on the consent
calendar so we already closed the
hearing
but I'm sure we can we can accommodate
that request and I in the interest of
time I say discuss I would like to
reopen the U executive session on hp1
125 so we can discuss the issue of
you uh this at this time we gonna U
hp25 at the time that we we went into
recess or suspended the executive
session
the was the point of order was amendment
has been offered but it doesn't have a
name of a member of the committee on the
amendment in order for a Committee
Member offered that Amendment still I
did consell with the
clerk uh and I was advised that a
member's name not have to be on the
amendment it's only required that a
member of the offer the so the amendment
that has representative Roy's name on it
not a member of can be offered by
representing the
board I will say going forward it is
still a great practice to getting
members name on the amendment because
you can probably count on that me
V representative ginate I believe you
were in the process of offering an
amendment do you mind reading that
amendment
number uh yes I still have uh would
202-3851
representative Roy U presented during
his testimony for
125 um it's very much similar to the
amendment you had offered earlier but
without a
penalty
um I think we should just uh accept the
amendment and pass the bill as
that Bradley you cing your screen are
you seconding the
amendment not second do someone wish to
Second
amendment true U I'm not trying to come
up to work but I believe the
representative when he made the motion
referred to
0385 it's
3085 which I don't have a copy of or is
0385 and even
newer
us representa if he had
conversation all right so GNA go we're
again Mr chairman sorry represent but
not the members in the room there are
three members physically present don't
have a
computer so they don't have a way to
read the amendment so I'm gon I said we
use our time another executive session
and the Mad clerk is contact print out
that Amendment down so we're going to
going to recess again on suspend the
executive session
[Music]
on
Mr
chair two
hands see two hands up I recommend that
we move on to House Bill the clerk the
committee assistant requested that that
amendment is brought down there's no
point in us going forth In fairness to
the members don't can't read it I only
expect can't
read represent but I I would say we have
a public hearing at two I can answer
questions but we're not get executive
sessions and I hear you guys like stay
L point of of order
recognized in order to vote for or
against an amendment it's under my end
understanding that in committee you must
have a written amendment in front of you
I agree with you 100% and that's why
we're not going forward with the
amendment right now and the committee
assistant been asked to bring it down
thank you I I would hope that people
don't just vote on amendments re so I
wouldn't expect anyone to do that so I
just say we move on to another one
better be brought now that's only in DC
Mr
chairman this time we're gonna open
reopen the executive session on
338 338 yes well we had a lengthy
[Music]
last and I will recognize representative
G for a motion of postive TK
off yes um thank you Mr chair is there a
second
by
represent speak on your
motion yes um in the hearing um I'm just
one of those that struggle with always
increasing penalties um when we have no
data on the previous increase in
penalties let's put it that way so um
I'd like to offer that whoever steals a
dog shall be guilty of a misom for the
first offense a class B felony for the
second offense and a class a felony for
have I just say I had an amendment
essentially doing what sort of what she
suggested her
better do you have a point of order do
you have a
question I we want to keep the point of
order as an objection inter
is this amendment
03428 being discuss now or I'm sorry I
should have said what mine was m is
room
very I will say there was competing
amendments one
Amendment there although I respect the
the amendment the idea was to not have
the dollar amount issue rep I think
amendment
that that thank you Mr chairman and
thank the representa for putting in an
amendment that is where I have a little
bit of
problem I want to try and wrap
everything into this problem B wants to
right and she wants to say the first
time somebody steals a dog it's a
misdemeanor and the person that does
steal the dog whether they're a minor or
an adult steals a eight or $9,000 dog is
enough
misdemeanor I leave that as a question
committee may I answer that Mr
chairman you may
respond thank you uh Mr chairman and
thank you f representative for the
question or statement um if I'm reading
this right I can support this
but I'm
assuming if little Bobby Tommy whatever
his name is steals an $8,000 dog this
goes out the window I'm guessing because
of the value which currently if you can
prove that dog is worth that much money
and I hope somebody will correct me if
I'm wrong um you've already gone up to a
class B felony I
believe thank you Mr chairman hopefully
wrong so the misdemeanor would be wiped
out I did I didn't give my copy of the
amends
away representative hoer thank you Mr
chairman um I would like the honor of
seconding the uh
uh amendment
0395 I don't think anybody seconded
it it was seconded by representative
well
[Music]
sorry and I will say I oh I agree that
this should be aelony I I advocated very
hard for that
last last time we were here
I didn't get any
and I was this is a concession on my end
this amendment but at the same time the
amendment fails I would support the bill
well I think this time we can put we can
put the U the call I see for the
hands the
um the question the floor is now whether
to adopt the
called representative sorry Vice
chairman Welsh
yes representative Bert yes
green represent restive Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative
true yes representative Pratt yes
representative Marston
no the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet GTH yes representative pakus
yes representative
o'n yes representative Gord
yes representative Muse
Newman
yes representative
Balden yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative Bradley
yes chairman
abis
shair vot
yes Mr chairman the vote is
19 by a v of 19 days
and name the amendment
pass now the mo the motion the pass with
amendment I believe we discussed this
already so go right to
Maron thank you Mr chairman I only
question I don't know if this a point
about I have before me I thought a an
amendment to this bill as well from
representative test and are we hearing
that or
not the one is so there only can be one
Amendment off all
right not to consider two amendments if
anything the Amendments would have to be
combined I will say the the Amendments
the way they're written do not coexist
in any way so
them is theair the chair discre
recognizes
understand very true thank you Mr chair
uh I heard in testimony
that current law states current law
since
1977 states that stealing a dog is a mis
mean now we have an amendment that says
stealing a dog is a Mis
me I I just think this gets Messier and
Messier um certainly worthy of of
retaining I do I'm not quite
sure I know what we're passing
now just seems very very messy Mr very
messy your point is well taken I think
the difference between what we're
be Class A Class B Class A I had my way
but the environment this room I didn't
think that was happen so I share you
[Music]
we either can itl it pass
it I still think a dog when I my wife
and I we bought a dog was $3,000 if we
stole $2,000 that's Class 8 I don't
understand how stealing a dog but that
point did not get me so right now I
rather than repeat myself in the last
hear I think the clerk can
with the question the clerk will call
the rooll motion is the cast Amendment
if you in support of the motion about C
please say yay if you are opposed please
say
names made
it yeah made you actually made this is
after I do the motion okay you recognize
to make a motion pass amend yes I moov O
pass as
amended
thank
out
you I thought I heard it I thought I'm
gonna play it back later but anyway you
can call the
RO Vice chman wel
hi representative B yes representative
Hopper yep
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true no representative
Pratt yes Representative morston
no the clerk votes
yes representative Harriet gatr yes
representative
panus yes representative o'n
yes representative gour yes
representative news
representative Newman votes
yes representative
Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative kle
Knight yes representative
abis chair votes
yes Mr chair
19 I Mo 19 Y and two
amended
second May able to get one more
ex repr thank you
a and I will also move to take it off
the consent so that I can speak to that
to
[Music]
pass
Mr
understand it's not going on consent he
objected to onent okay before I Clos it
last time I closed I already closed it
it
yes I'd just like to say thank you to
times representative panelas it's what
you have on the side of your cushion
me recognize for point of order I hope
we have representative speaking out of
don't I don't think that's a point of
order you know let's just move on to we
can actually rather than debate points
of order that whether it is a point we
have nine minutes so we don't stay past
five I think we can sneak in another
executive session for 2 o' I believe the
amendment is now here for HP 125 is that
correct all right let's open the
executive
hb5 and at this point time represent
boin thank you Mr chair I would like to
offer Amendment a
202-
0385 uh this is basically the amendment
presented this
amendment I'll
second just to be clear there was a
motion previously made about the pass
off the amendment just that was a couple
hours ago so just to clarify that repres
just to clean it up for the people
listening you want to just restate your
motion I ought to pass it off the
second
did he hear
you representative Bo just to clarify
for the members of the public listening
at home because you did make a motion of
the pass offer an amendment that was
about two hours ago so I think this for
the purpose of public interest to make
sure everyone's falling along quickly do
you mind just restating your
motion the motion is to uh a to pass
laws or rsas punish
crime there's no
punishment if you violate this this uh
this bill this bill becomes law there's
no punishment I don't see any value in
passing anything if there's no way to
well I was going to say this last time
but uh you were more concerned about
everybody in the room but I have not
received a revised copy of that uh
now
thank you for bringing that to my to our
attention the m cler is forwarding you a
copy by
email representative
[Music]
Muse thank you Mr chair I just like to
point out that you know that one of the
things that we try to do through
legislation as well uh especially in
this committee is to protect Public
Safety um we also uh look at privacy
issues um I think one of the things that
we struggle with all the time is how
much to penalize people or to not
penalize people um I think
representative Roy really sort of Hit
the hit the nail on the head when he
said that this bill you know basically
hits a a sweet spot what it what it does
is it prevents Behavior Uh that's
potentially harmful to an individual
long-term who's never been convicted of
a crime um but what it what it also what
it also Al seems to do is it also seems
to split the difference with the
Public's right to know so um there's
nothing in this bill that prevents a
person's name uh from from being printed
or that wouldn't make their name subject
to a a right to no request so what it
what it really does seem to do uh is to
really kind of hit the nail on the head
when it comes to that situation the
representative Klein Knight described
which is you know somebody literally on
the worst night of their life who might
not even be convicted of the crime
having their picture permanently in
social media maybe for the rest of their
life and being subject to uh to ridicule
um to me uh that seems to be a situation
that's you know worth taking care of and
that's within the purview of this
of Representative Maron thank than you
Mr chairman um I simply want to
acknowledge what my colleague he crossed
way from the representative true
mentioned that there's no penalty
involved in this and with that being
said I will make a I will vote no on
amendments
representative should you need to
recognize represent poer first represent
poer thank you Mr chair um just a uh a
little bit about
strategy
um it is a bill like this is a lot
easier to get through without a penalty
it's a lot more likely to make it
through the Senate be signed by the
governor and in the next legislative
session if we find that police are not
abiding by it that would be the time to
add a penalty if we add a penalty to
begin with then we'll have the forces
arrayed against us and it'll never make
it through the Senate so strategically
the amendment is a lot better than
adding the
penalty
thanks and I'm just going to say I
understand that there's some issues with
not having a penalty
that this is where we are now I
agree I think this bill would be better
asserted that had a penalty written in
there but that amend failed
so I still think that the the policy is
is really good policy and I I'm going to
the representative B thank you Mr chair
um I was actually basically going to say
the same thing that representative uh
Hopper said but he said it better than I
offer hands raised call the
all the question the put the question is
whether to
adopt
Amendment
0385 in favor of adopting
am please say y if you are opposed
r Vice chairman Welch yes representative
ber yes representative Hopper yes ma'am
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true n representative
Pratt yes representative Marston
no the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet Gaff yes representative
pacus yes representative
no
representative Bo May
yes representative Muse
yes representative
Newman
H representative
bden
yes representative Conley
yes representative K Knight
yes representative Bradley
yes I vot of 18 Y and three Nays the
amendment has been
adopted make sure we get this right the
board would you like to be recognized to
yes Mr chairman I would like to offer
that a motion I um move that
second
to speak to your motion excuse me sorry
discussion can can I just verify what
you have this legislative
email
certainly
is one word
no let
discuss it's a motion
18 thank you for the
clarification
I
think question right now see no hands
raised
discuss
motion the motion is app app to pass as
amended if you in favor please say yay
n Vice chairman
W
yes represent B yes representative
Hopper yep representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative Tru y representative prep
morston
no clerk votes yes representative
yes representative
pakus
yes Representative
o'n
no representative B
yes representative musees
Newman
yes representative
bden yes representative Conley yes
representative kle Knight
yes representative
Bradley
yes chairman
abis chair vot
19 by a vote of 19 years and two n the
motion of to pass as
amended passed Mr chairman if there's
not going to be a floor fight I would
recommend consent but if there's going
to be a floor fight then is there any
consent I don't
understand that what Mr representative
bur said about a floor flight I don't
think you have to have a FL fight for
every bill but I think by if
something passes with some no
votes so I think somebody ought to be
able to speak about why they voted no
and let the house itself not get into a
big fight but just understand the
arguments and maybe they will too decide
to vote no on the whole thing in the
house we just CL when representative
bird saying FL fight I don't think he
means that negative under it's often a
ice so if there is two
objections two name in the rest of pass
what can happen is if you put on consent
and that usually when a matter is on
consent it means that there won't be a
four debates on the bill or on on the
rec the motion so with that being said
if someone were to remove it froment
being removed tradition is the person
removing it normally would be the member
participating in the FL debate so I I I
believe what representative saying if if
you don't intend on participating in for
debate he's I think suggesting or trying
to encourage you not to object to this
going
on that's my understand it is but what
we can do it's 208 we do have a public
hearing at 2 o' members of the public
waiting if you have questions we can I I
say I can say after five answer I just
want to
keep everything going is this a question
about the consent
calar okay last
question you're objecting on consent yes
I am objecting to the consent
[Music]
calendar
okay representative Newman you have
a hand
up yes I didn't but I think it was just
say answered by that thank you very much
wish thank you at this time we'll close
the the executive session on House Bill
[Music]
125 at this time we opening the public
hearing on House Bill 93 that will be
of of the members of the public
testimony will be limited to one
minute for each the members of the
public with the exception to the
bill and it's with
that
representative it's hard to hear from
you yes
uh uh thank you Mr chair for the
opportunity to speak to HB 93
FN before you begin I just want to say
that when I say it's it's great to hear
from you we all praying for you it's
good to hear you it's nice to be here I
almost wasn't so through a covid battle
it was uh almost took my life but I'm
coming back strong and off oxygen for a
week
so may may proceed sir yes you may
s
um imagine a kid walking into uh a movie
theater to watch an our
movie or going into a strip club and of
course they can't but they can take any
smartphone and do it uh any smartphone
and get into that material there may be
a saave search that can turn off but
they can get at it and so this this
Bill uh puts a filter in uh to to
prevent that from happening does not
prevent any adult from accessing any
material they want they can sign up to
remove the filter for a nominal fee um
and that the money going from that fee
to the state it is to is toh support
anti-child trafficking initiatives and
there's a list in the Bill of what that
would do and this this uh bill as
written passes Constitution muster
because Supreme Court and other courts
have found out that filtering is a least
harmful way of of of
of blocking material objectionable
material so it does pass constitutional
muster it does protect our children uh
both from seeing un materials they
should not see and protect them from
nutshell
[Music]
hands
raised
representative you are excuse than
[Music]
yes you recognize introdu HP thank you
Mr chairman good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee I'm
representative Linda Mima and I
represent the towns of lyleton and
Bethlehem as some of the past committee
Representatives might recognize that
hb10 was presented in 2019 as
hb21 and it was referred to interim stud
that summer came out of study with a to
pass recommendation and then came out of
the committee with that
recommendation in a roll call vote in
2020 the house voted 314 to 55 to pass
hb21 which moved on to the Senate and
then covid happened and the rest is
history the bill before you HB 180 is
the same bill as it was as
hb21 it would increase the penalty for
purchases of sex with a minor from a
Class B to a class a felony it
eliminates distinctions between
traffickers and buyers by recognizing
the equal role buyers play in creating a
supply and demand Marketplace for the
buying and selling of trafficked
children for
sex current law classifies the act of
person's purchasing sex with a minor as
a class B felony which carries a three
and a half to 7year prison term and a
fine of no greater than
$4,000 hb180 would raise the penalty to
S and a half to 15 years with the same
monetary
penalty so what crimes are classified as
Class B and class A felonies in New
Hampshire class B felonies in New
Hampshire include Computer Fraud
possession of small amounts of illegal
substances driving while intoxicated
fourth offence and above theft of
property valued at more than 500 but
less than
$1,000
shoplifting simple ass salt and the
buying of sex with a
minor class A felonies include
murder
manslaughter kidnapping theft of
property over
$1,000 SE second or subsequent
conviction for aggravated felonious
sexual assault and Drug
crimes judges have sentencing discretion
even in felony cases unless the minimum
sentence is mandatory and their de their
discretion is to whether to sentence to
prism time probation or unconditional or
conditional discharge by factoring such
things as the defendant's criminal
record the extent of injury or damage
caused the impact of the crime on the
victim or the community and the extent
to which the defendant has addressed
life
circumstances such as
addiction as of
2017 according to the National criminal
justice reference service
41 States has statutes that make
penalties for the buyers of commercial
sex acts with miners as high or almost
as high as the federal penalties which
are if a child is under the age of 14 or
if Force fraud or coercion was used a
penalty of not less than 15 years in
prison up to life is imposed and if the
victim is 14 to 17 years the the minimum
is not less than 10 but also up to
life so who are these buyers of sex with
minors a Boston psychology study by
Melissa Farley at all founds that the
income levels Spann from the lowest of
$40,000 the
education um the education of these
buyers 40% of them were college or
graduate with had a college of graduate
degree the race was mostly White and the
gender was male and the age was 20 to 75
married the economic principles of
supply and man is driven by the
demand the sex trade is founded on that
principle according to the Brooklyn Law
School in their Journal of Law and
policy the fastest way to dismantle a
market is to dissolve the demand and a
study from the D Department of Justice
put this actly quote without the demand
for commercial sex there would be no
Market forces forces producing and
sustaining the roles of pimps and
traffickers as Distributors nor would
there be a force driving the production
of a supply of people to be sexually
exploited Supply and distribution are
symptoms
cause I am sensitive to and in I in
support of critical and meaningful
criminal justice reform efforts and I'm
in full support of that however I am
simultaneously listening to survivors
service providers and Advocates who
continuously deal detail the severe harm
that buyers caused we are talking about
people who are paying to rape children
and who our criminal justice systems
have historically
ignored not over or unjustly
criminalized buyers have historically
been insulated by meaningful criminal
account by meaningful criminal
accountability because of their social
status if we are willing to hold the
traffickers largely people who are not
white m middle class men accountable
with class A penalties then we must be
willing to hold those who are actually
committing the sexually violent acts
against children to the same
standard regarding deterrence it's all
but impossible to measure deterrence
simple because we are talking about an
act that never occurred or never came to
full fruition
however penalties are not simply put in
place to deter a crime they are put in
place to hold offenders accountable to
bring Justice to survivors and to
increase Community
safety
when House Bill
201 came up for um a
vote Governor cunu sent to the chairman
uh chairman Cushing at the time a letter
that said it is imperative that we take
this immediate action to further protect
victims of sex trafficking I am writing
you today to express my support of what
was then House Bill 201 relative to
enhancing penalties for sex fires
exploiting traffic
children it is my hope that the
committee will strongly Endor the
measure
at one time New Hampshire was a leader
against human trafficking as we were one
of the first States to criminalize this
activity as a result service providers
across the state have been able to
assist survivors of sex and labor
trafficking to help rebuild their lives
we must continue that tradition signed
Governor Christopher
sonunu thank you for
listening
representa thank you very much for your
your
testimony thank
you seeing No Hands raised oh excuse me
representative
coordin thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you realize that
we changed this uh the penalty for this
in
2017 uh to a class B
felony uh as that made it a
difference again as I I stated in my
opening testimony that detur is really
something that hasn't or seems not to be
able to be measured simply because it is
a crime it's a crime that is
not that never occurred or it never came
measure
representa thank you for thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um you listed some states with
stiff how come we're not asking for
those penalties in
this um I'm sorry representative you are
breaking up so I couldn't hear the
question dur your testimony you talked
about some states that has some very s
compared to
these say that
again could somebody sort of translate
what he's saying because he's really
breaking up and I'm only getting C of
the
question during your during your
testimony you talked about some states
that have a very strong penalty
yes why did why aren't you trying for
those kind of
penalties because those type of
penalties are exactly what went along
with the federals federal guidelines and
I know that looking at Criminal Justice
Reform we're trying to um take in
consideration the
perpetrators um background and motives
victims
okay representative Bo
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um so in line seven and
eight neither the actor's lack of
knowledge or other person's age nor
consent of the other person will
constitute a defense in a charge under
this paragraph now we're looking at a
felony charge so there usually in a
major crime like this we need intent and
you are basically saying that intent is
taken out of the equation
is is that what you really want to
happen again can you repeat your
question maybe it's on my end of the
computer but I'm having a hard time
hearing you fine lines uh seven and
eight neither the actor's lack of
knowledge of the other person's age
nor uh consent of the person shall
constitute a defense to a charge under
this paragraph now we are talking about
a penalty of a Class A
uh
felony um you're taking
out uh intent as as a as uh part of the
uh uh justification of of the penalty is
that really what you want to
do when you say taking out the intent
what do you mean usually when you have
are looking at a major crime that you're
going to be found guilty of you have to
actually do it and you have to actually
intend to do it and uh right now you've
taken intent
away well if if you're referring to the
one about the actor's lack of knowledge
that is already in um
law in New Hampshire as far as they
cannot use that as a defense yes but
that is as a a class B felony which I
think is is a little different than a
class a felony because you're looking at
Major prison
time you're ma you're looking at Major
prison time as far as it would be eight
more years than the top penalty for
class
B
um when you're talking about children
and you're clunking them in a class B
felony that has to do with Computer
Fraud and shoplifting I really think
that our value of children should not be
clumped with Computer Fraud and driving
intoxicated for the fourth offense so
when I first introduced the bill for
class B felony I was told as you know
that when you introduce things you
should go in small
increments so instead of going to a
class a felony immediately I decide I
was it was suggested that I start with a
Class B and that's what I
did thank
you thank
you representative
G um thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question representative
um my question is has there been any
data captured
since um the bill changed from misdem to
across
[Music]
follow
clarification any data around um since
it was um changed to a class B felony
you have any data as to what effect it's
had on um I guess uh people doing the
again um I have looked for thata
like that um representative but
unfortunately the data does not seem to
be there as far as the effects of this
because obviously you would have to do
some sort of survey of people who might
be intending to have sex with a minor
but I don't think you would have a very
willing um sample come forward to
participate in that type of a survey and
um so I don't I I haven't seen any data
regarding
that the data that I was referring to is
people that have been arrested has there
been any um increase in um the arrestes
or decreases in the arrestes that's what
I'm looking for when I was speaking of
the data okay I I checked with the
Department of Corrections and at the
state prison in New Hampshire they do
you being No Hands raised I want to
thank the representa for her
excuse I just want to remind members of
the public that testimony will be
stepen k
n there's a Stephen K Mr chairman would
that be him or Steve
try
asked him to
unmute just remind your testimony is
minute he's not unmuting Mr
yes yman can you hear me you can I thank
you so much for hearing my testimony
today for the record my name is Darlene
Pollock I am a juvenile sex trafficking
Survivor from here in New Hampshire I
was 13 years old when I was groomed for
trafficking I was Ked at 14 I was 90
pounds barely developed and the men who
bought me wanted my youth when I was 16
and 17 years old being trafficked with
other girls my age we were already too
old for some
buyers I went through a lot of physical
uh mental um disease all kinds of
terrible things during my time being
trafficked it was violent very often
when people think of buying sex they
think of buying sex like you would have
with someone you care for this is not
what happens when people buy sex very
often I have a lot of comp passion for
young people I understand they're
growing up in a hypers sexualized
hyperviolet world right now but I ask
you to pass House Bill 180 and send a
message to buyers that New Hampshire is
not going to allow them to buy children
you thank you very much for your
tman thank you for letting me ask this
question thank you so much Char
um do you think that we should pass a
bill that would somehow carve out an
where person was under
20 having sex with somebody 15 or
16 I do sir and the reason for that is
because their their brains just aren't
developed and they can't really tell how
old a person is sometimes I think that
that would be um a beneficial carve
you I expect you would still leave it as
a class B felony for that age
group thank you see seeing No Hands
raised I want to thank the witness for
her testimony thank you very much sir
thank you members in of the
committee Steve K has has his hand
right hello can you hear me okay yes and
just a reminder your testimony is
limited to one minute and please clarify
whether you are testifying support of a
house bill 93 House Bill 180
or I'm testifying in favor of
um human trafficking is a modern form of
slavery its perpetrators methodically
identify vulnerable people especially
young women and then groom them for
monetary gain through
enslavement as a society we owe it to
these victims to give law enforcement
the necessary tools to reduce demand for
the sex services on which such slavery
thrives House Bill 180 provides one such
tool for our law enforcement
statement I want to thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands
exuse
Jessica
name
yes well thank you for the opportunity
to hear what I have to say I'm asking
you to support the bip bipartisan Bill
HB 93 my name is Cam olette I'm from New
London and I work with special forces of
Liberty de facto attorney generals I'm
asking you to protect young minds and
Next Generation from lurking dangers
these children are our future the future
of our families the future of our nation
pornography is a drug it triggers an
addictive response in the brain just
like we protect our young people from
the dangers of drug and alcohol we must
also protect their minds from
pornography modern technology has
created new problems that we must
urgently solve our children are carrying
around access to the Internet and mobile
devices with no restrictions we must
protect the innocent of the youth with
all the fervor that we have by demanding
all products with access to the internet
be sold with the safety of our children
put first by protecting them from the
dangers of pornographic material please
vote in favor of HB 93 the human
trafficking and child exploitation
prevention act thank
you
testimony see seeing No Hands raised the
witness
quinland Mr chairman I do not see any
Greg on the list sener for Garden State
families oh
there lobbyist if there's any members of
the public wish to testify on House Bill
hands hello Mr chairman members of the
Committees thank you so much for having
me uh Greg quinland Jessica some other
members have been trying to get on but
they've just had some technical
technical difficulty but I think I can
speak on their behalf but former Judge
Advocate General former assistant un
States Attorney this bill was written
out of a multitude of multi-state
federal litigation over 20 states are
moving on this bill there's a trigger
provision included in House Bill 93 by
representative PL that requires at least
four other states pass the bill before
it becomes law this is a bill that says
going forward the state any retailer
manufacturer of an Internet enabled
device is required to install a filter
that automatically blocks by default
websites that are known to facilitate
human trafficking and prostitution and
websites that display x-rated material
that would be injurious to Children if
the consumer is an adult they w't have
access to adult websites they can they
got to show proof of ID to the retailer
and pay a one-time fee of n nominal fee
of $20 is remitted back to the state to
go to a grant fund administered by the
the Attorney General's office to finance
any group that's working to uphold
Community standards of decency or combat
sex related offenses I got four quick
talking points number one as CW versus
the ACLU the Supreme Court of the United
States found that Congress the
legislative branch may undoubtly act to
encourage the use of filters that
encourage parents to use filters and the
tech companies to develop better filter
technology that was was the Supreme
Court informing the legislative branch
to pass this bill number two Ginsburg
versus New York Supreme Court decision
where they upheld the constitutionality
of the display statute New Hampshire has
that Statute in place that's the statute
that requires the gas stations than the
new stands to put x-rated material
behind a blind Ora that can only be
removed the consumer as an adult they
show proof of ID and pay for it number
three the the we always normally start a
hearing when we have a lot of time by
saying why is it that a
12-year-old we have to limit testimony
to one minute your time has expired you
went over by about 20 seconds however
represent B you do have a question for
the wits yes I do thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question um
how many states currently did you say
have this uh a similar Bill and does it
work in those States because I know kids
are you know if I need um anything done
on my cell phone I bring it to my
grandkids and they fix it uh yes sir so
first of all there four states have
passed the last section of the bill we
call it the admission act when it's run
separately Texas was the first state
that's the part that says you got to pay
$5 to enter a strip club that goes to
the same Grant fund that the onetime $20
filter deactivation fee goes to that has
been incredibly successful it's been
challenged it went to the Texas Supreme
Court and the Texas Supreme Court upheld
that in a case called comes versus Texas
entertainment for two reasons number one
the fee is nominal and number two the
fee doesn't go to the general fund it
goes to all of these kind of groups like
the child advocacy centers and the human
trafficking task force and things of
that nature now Utah has passed a filter
Statute in 2006 and it says this it says
going forward in that state uh if a
person has an ISP Comcast AT&T they can
demand that the ISP install a filter but
they can charge a filter installation
fee so members of our team sued the
state of Utah in 2016 to say you guys
got that backwards it should be that the
filter comes on the front end and
instead of subjecting consumers like
schools parents and teachers and
children to a filter installation fee
there should be a filter activation fee
now the the company should keep a piece
of that but the state needs a part of
that so we can Finance all of these
great groups in New Hampshire that we've
been talking with that you know are
fighting to uphold Community standards
of decency so but no state has passed
the filter bill but I mean every state
touching you basically is running the
measure I I can name the sponsors be
sir seeing no the hands raised the
chairman we have a John Jr and uh just
please State your full name for the
record where you are from and whether
which bill you were testifying on behalf
of and whether you were in support or an
opposition testimon is lied to one
minute
can you hear me okay yes we can okay
thank you thank you chairman members of
the committee yeah my name is John
Gunter Jr and I work with a group called
The Clean Services foundation and the
special force of Liberty we've been
fighting pornography for about 15 years
and human trafficking for about six as
we know that human trafficking and
pornography are highly
linked and we have children in every
state that we run by we we work with
groups we work with legislators we're
trying to do the best thing we can to
protect our children for the future I've
got three children three girls and a boy
and they have run into pornography on
quote unquote accident and we know that
they're being targeted and we know they
are being um coerced into seeing
material that is not constitutional for
them to see as a child or is not safe
for their minds and we know that sex is
great in the right context but when it
comes to a child in certain forms in
certain areas of pornography it is
demeaning it is demoralizing and it
gives them the wrong perception of what
the human body is for and what the the
nature of sex is for so I would vote in
93 thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused this time chair is recognizing
Bob
dun just please State whether you're
testifying in support opposition to uh
House Bill 93 or House Bill
180 where you're from yeah thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee I'm
Bob Dunn the director of public policy
for the Roman Catholic dasis of
Manchester and I'm here today to
register our support for HB
180 um human trafficking is something
that is of major concern to the Catholic
Church here in New Hampshire and across
the world uh Pope Francis in fact is
called human trafficking nothing less
than a crime against
humanity hb180 focuses on the most
egregious forms of this most egregious
crime right now by definition we have a
class B type of penalty for what is
clearly a Class A Sort of crime in terms
of its gravity so passing 180 would send
the right message to wbe buyers and
traffickers and importantly to their
you thank you Mr dun for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused we have it just says Christine's
Galaxy but Christine please State your
full name for the record where you're
testifying from and whether you're
testifying in support or opposition to
House Bill 93 and or House Bill 18 and
my name is Christine wheelie and I am
the founder of one heart Ministries um
Minnesota and I am testifying in regards
to House Bill 93 I fully support this
bill and I have uh one of my Ministry
Partners has sent over a written uh
testimony to you in regards to that I
just want to say uh quickly that I
Minister and a pastor families um who
have had devastations due to the
addictions that pornography has uh has
and so this filter up front on the fore
end of it will help protect the families
marriages and the children who um have
access to uh these devices um and so I
just wanted to just say vote in favor of
testimony seeing No Hands
raised
yes can you hear me yes we can hear you
just a reminder your testimony is
limited to one minute yes sir hi my name
is Tiffany marer I'm the co-founder and
vice chair of no more tiers 214 and the
director of Missouri for Special Forces
of Liberty I'm also a Survivor
consultant and a survivor of human
trafficking I am in support support of
HB 93 here today and I ask that you
please do support this because this is
going to drastically drastically change
the way that we Implement and help our
children today I was a victim of
everything that is in your bill I have
submitted a nice long written testimony
so I'm going to keep this very short um
you can read it and I attached a picture
along it to do it with my Survivor story
because I am an author and there's no
way for me to get this any shorter than
I absolutely already have for you guys
time thank you for your testimony know
excused question
yeah
someone was supposed to come testify I
guess told to get's
name right well if there are any members
of the public who have not testified
already that are in
hand
Jessica I do not see a
Jessica double
check no and what's the last name Mr
chairman and ne ne ne l
y
name all right at this time uh we will
close the public hearing on House Bill
93 and we close the public
we are recognizing the representative
there is a name of a member of the
public I believe you want
toap right
about please refesh
M okay thank you Mr chair um I just
wanted to say that when Darlene Pollock
testified a
representative made a suggestion that
maybe a carat or an amendment be made to
to keep a class B felony for um buyers
under the age of 20 I believe and I just
want to let you know that I would
support that as long as the class A
stayed for buyers above that
than hey see see represent walls thank
you Mr chairman um this repr do
representative Muse have the uh numbers
of these two bills before we
close representative Muse you wish to
read the uh the numbers of support and
opposition from House Bill yes I do for
House Bill 180 uh 196 people signed in
in support and uh only two people signed
in uh in
opposition and for House Bill
93 uh nine people signed in in support
opposition
thank at this time we will close the
public hearing on
hp93 and the public he HB
180 you will stand in
recess uh to to 3
p.m. we'll be will be conducting some
memb
e
okay
good afternoon
time we are the chair opening the
C8 recognizing representative Wallace
for a
motion chairman I move to pass on
CAC is there a second I'll
second motion the pass is
seconded by representative
green representative W you wish to speak
on your
motion yes Mr chairman I'll speak to
that briefly uh
cacr will send message to the federal
government that uh we here in New
Hampshire uh support respect and to
reaffirm and defend the article 2A here
in New Hampshire uh pursuing to All
Things firearm and accessory and that
the uh should the federal government
take action that may be more restrictive
that we're going to hold our own and
keep things the way they have been in
the future and maintain the
power god-given right to self-defense by
possible
represa
M yes thank you Mr chairman I am um
definitely not going to support this
bill um uh essentially what this would
do is it would it would act to cut off
public debate uh I understand the desire
to protect uh the Second Amendment but
clearly we're doing it at the expense of
the First Amendment uh in this
particular case uh I don't believe that
we should be uh tying the hands of
future legislators um when it comes to
uh to changing our gun laws especially
thing especially laws uh that would
actually increase safety um for gun
owners and other members of the public
um this is uh this is bad public policy
and to put it in the state constitution
mistake oh and one other thing that I
did want to also raise additionally is
it is extremely challenging and
difficult to try to respond uh to
executing these bills with absolutely no
notice uh that they're coming um as a
courtesy uh to other members of the
committee I would ask the chairman going
forward uh to at least uh give us notice
of a few minutes of which bills
willes if you are I understand the pr
that you're making right now you're
recognized to speak
on the whether support opposition of the
motion of at the pass CAC if you want to
discuss the the practice of the chair
that's for a different time you not
recognize so I'd ask that we just stick
to the topic for now I didn't understand
your
frustration you wish to continue
speaking to
CAC I'm I am done with ca8 and I hope
well I will recognize represent
representative Bradley
speak thank you chair um I will be
opposing this bill as well and I agree
with with representative news um it just
doesn't allow allow for any debate going
forward um this really ties the hands of
of anybody that wants to talk about
sensible um gun
legislation um yeah so I I I agree with
oppose thank you represent
representative
Kerman I'll be supporting this but this
been about cutting off debate
we're seeing that every day today this
doesn't make it good or not you can't
talk about uh collection you can't talk
about some question about vaccines you
kicked off of
Facebook that's just not an excuse
besides there's a tenament that says
people the people get make these kind
States and people get to make these
kinds of decisions not the federal
government
representative
Newman
CRA thank you Mr chair I'll also be
opposed to this
bill and mainly because I think that
some of the language even goes to
bringing up votes and and voting on it
and it just seems that uh this cuts off
the debate and that would be in our
Constitution and the kind of Co that the
previous member just talked about not
being able to debate that that's
something that private companies have
done none of that is in the Constitution
so I will be opposed to this vote I'm a
vot I'm opposed to the way we did this
executive hearing and I won't have
anything else to say about this we have
no way to
chair
your objection to the executive session
has been
noted representa Maron thank you Mr
chairman I have a note here to myself
and I want to question about that do we
have an amendment to the C and is it in
the works or
what there I have not seen any Amendment
nor is anyone offered an amendment on to
CR representative Wallace thank you Mr
chair just a question uh to the members
who oppose of this on the basis that it
makes that it stifles public uh input um
and the questions you do realize that
should this pass the house and the
Senate it will go onto the ballot for
the citizens in to vote on which I can't
think of any other way to get more
public input by putting question
of Representative
board thank you Mr chairman uh the clerk
can correct me if I'm wrong but I sort
of remember the
NRA um and
uh Penny and uh Other Bar arms groups uh
saying this was a bad bill so I don't
know why we're spending much time on it
thank
you representative y um I also want to
oppose this bill um I just want to um
remind people that um at the end of the
day of that hearing the support was 35
and the the opposition was 166 and even
more importantly uh Gun Owners of
America were
neutral so you know that long you know
by itself says that obviously there's
other more work to be done or there's a
bill representative roads Mr chairman I
I just wanted to um say something in
regards to with respect to
representative ter G just said which was
we do hear that a lot that you know how
many people were here today testify but
I think that sometimes we fail to take
into account how many people have come
up to us in our person and or sent
countless emails that we all receive and
my personal email exploded with
overwhelmingly yes to all anything that
that fin thank you Mr chairman I just
have a question since I was not here for
this debate some could you or or someone
in the room remind me the threshold if
this makes it to the Val then become
what the number that it would have to
hit I'm G answer this I hope I get right
sure some correct I believe in the house
it's require 60% vote as well as the
Senate at that point if it's on the
ballot we need
two know that you I believe you're
majority the other comment that I would
like is at least when we get the um the
testify sheet we can see the telephone
numbers and when I can say is the
majority of those were 603 numbers all
right however what comes in our mailbox
States so I so basically if I'm GNA pay
attention to something I'm going to be
looking at you know where those uh
people that are are for or closing or or
um for a bill I'm really looking at
their telephone numbers or their
addresses that they provide
that and I will say I
think in respect of that do get the 60%
voted sign go to the bot every person
they support
opposition assuming they resent of the
state time will be have opport to V on I
think that's the that matters most
that
the see no no hand hands
raised for anyone who hasn't spoke
already would like to speak you may you
may raise your hand speak we do want to
keep things
moving ladies and gentlemen we got a lot
of
bills going so seeing No Hands raised
for people haven't uh spoke
already called the rooll matter question
the motion is to pass if you would
support please say yay
please Vice chairman
Welch yes representative B
yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative marsten yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet
GA no Representative
pacus
beginning we have this happen again well
let's continue with the role and then
I'll address
okay representative Bard a
no representative muse no representative
Newman no representative
Balden no representative Conley no
representative Klein Knight no
representative
Bradley
no
I see him up there you see him yeah the
chair
is
see
Ray no that's Ray I'm
[Music]
chair votes
119 I vot of 11 y the
nine motion
pass
wallity
one
Report
recogniz I think you
muted chair um I am a little concerned
about what bills we are executing on
each day uh I understand and it it's
legal to to exact bills that we are
hearing the day that we are without any
other notice so we heard on other days
without public notice I think is a issue
uh there uh should there are people that
are interested in those bills and if
they're not know notice that there are
going to be an executive session then uh
you didn't complain last
year was
a representative B your concern is
understandable I will say that this the
rules uh that we've adopted the
executive session to be conducted this
way on under regular circumstances I
would share your philosophy on how to
schedule executive session
I'm not going to feel other questions or
any responses to what I'm saying now
this is the rule the chair has the
discretion to call the executive session
represent I'm not going to recognize
anyone to speak so you want to keep your
hand up you can I'm just explaining it's
within disc of the chair if I even
hinted at when executive sessions were
going to be called a lot of it depends
on the scheduling and how much time we
have between the hearings so I couldn't
even give you that if I want to even lay
it out for you I couldn't actually do
so it would be more misleading for me to
give you a schedule but KN one you
wouldn't follow it but this is permitted
and I recommend to everyone for any
bills that have public hearing to be
prepared for to go towards an executive
session that's the best I can offer
right now um the only and I've been very
I would say I've been very fair with it
I don't I don't when people get up I
don't try to take advantage of situation
so I'm not gonna take any questions on
this right now we're going to move on to
the next executive session I want to use
the hour and a half we have um wisely if
you'd like to discuss your concern for
me after do our own time right but this
time I'm going to close the executive
R8 this time we're going open open the
executive session on House Bill
93 chair recognizes representative hoer
ret the chair withdraws that recognition
repres that motion seconded by
representative
discuss representative M recognize to
discuss the motion to retain
l93 thank you um this is probably the
biggest trash bill that's been submitted
to us so far um nine pages long um uh a
cryptic fiscal note and only people from
out of state who came to testify on it
I have absolutely no idea why the motion
[Music]
bill representa gaer I would have to
agree 100% with representative M um and
particularly once he said no state has
passed the F
Bill no the state has even wanted to
it
listen now the time to speak up is you
represent wel to withraw his motion
before just did it again that's three
times
you respect the process
[Music]
everyone all right so and and we don't
have to do a roll call to withdraw the
motion to retain no it is I'm just going
to for the sake of it is there a second
to withdraw that motion even though we
don't need a second represent wall
second in that request all right now the
floor is
open would someone like to be wrecking
represent brought your hands up let me
take it down I just had a comment now
it's
down representative B your hand is up
thank you Mr chair I like to make a
motion to uh uh make to rule this bill
in expedient to Alle site itl I mean
second I mean I never got to Second
[Music]
yet represent we like you recognize the
second the motion itl thank you I second
it thank you it's official
now is
uh it's already been discussed by a few
members is there any further discussion
to have
on on the motion of to legislate
93 your hand is raised yes thank you Mr
chairman I just want to State for the
record that
I have a new friend on this bill
representative Muse and I'm going to
vote with him because I totally agree
what he said I mean it
yourself never wanting to miss an
opportunity to agree with representative
Bert I also will vote to itl this
bill
you sure you don't want to retain
it seeing No Hands
raised not call the r the M put the
question is the a motion of inexpedient
to legisl you in support of the motion
to inexpedient to legislate please say
yay if you are opposed please say
n Vice chairman Welch yes representative
no representative green yes
representative Wallis yes Representative
testerman
no representative true yay
representative pre yes representative
Marston
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet GTH yes representative
pacus
yes representative bordon yes
Newman
yourself
yes representative
Balden yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative
Bradley yes chairman abis two votes
o' text me having
[Music]
problem as
a vote of 18 days and two n the motion
of inexp legislate
objections none now close the executive
93 this
time here will open the executive
recogniz
second
I'll
second oh he
already you wish to speak to your
motion I think earlier today I I spoke
to my motion I'm just getting more and
more concerned with intrusion on my
privacy my
iPhone and everything
else
discussion
representative thank you um chair uh
thank you everyone I
really um I'm
sorry uh I'm not trying to be
disrespectful uh representative but I
just don't find this necessary at all
because whenever you download something
or enter into a contract with an
electronic company tech company you as
the consumer are already made aware and
fine print of your rights and you
actually have to click on I accept these
rights in order to use this software or
Hardware or it is your choice to go on
your daily business and that is a
contract that's already enabled and and
informs people of the rights what this
is going to do is not change anything
except there's a fiscal note which is
going to cost our people money I don't
think this is enforcable with your
intent your intent is good I get it we
shouldn't be taking advantage of people
that don't know what's happening on
their electronic devices but again it's
their consumers
responsibility and with that I I can't
support this I don't think it's fair to
people that are aware and know how to
use technology and for the taxpayers to
pay uh you know on something that
somebody else just isn't educated enough
on how to turn their privacy settings on
is just not fair to the rest of the
state thank you represent
n representative
Muse I would have to agree with
representative Klein Knight um I think
one of the things that's incumbent on on
everybody in the digital age is to know
how to manage their own individual
privacy settings uh and when it came to
finding the co ab app uh representative
testerman didn't have any problems
finding it and when he found it it
hadn't been activated he chose not to
activate it he wasn't tracked I don't
understand why we need a state law in
this
situation
up represent
Bo thank you Mr chair I I have a
question is is this bill going to a
second
committee it's excellent question I
so it looks like it should be have come
know
well the extent that it is the second me
guaranteed
see no further hands
raised the matter we put the question
the mo the clerk call the RO the motion
is H to pass if you in support of the
motion please say yay if you are opposed
please say
nay Vice chairman Welch yes
representative B yes representative
Hopper yes representative green yay
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Marston
yay the clerk votes yes representative
mute turn video on
no I I taking it off 100% postive that's
on
Oar representative B no
representative news
no representative
Newman no representative Balden
no representative Conley no
representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman
yes
by a vote of 11 to n 11
Y and
[Music]
on
someing
report I will take just to take the
pressure off
question this time we will close the
executive session on House Bill
at this
time CH will open the executive session
for House Bill
[Music]
485 recognized representative hoer make
a motion of OD to pass I believe you
offering an amendment is that correct me
if I'm wrong is that Amendment
2021 049
wow psychic yes Mr chairman I'd like to
uh make a motion about to pass on house
485 and I would move amendment
04098 is there a
second I'll second it that that motion
has been seconded by representative
B speak to the
amendment uh I think the amendment
basically
clarifies
that if somebody stopped and the police
officer asked to certific car there has
to be
verification that the person gave their
consent so I support the amendment and
the bill I think the
U especially for younger people when
they're confronted with police officer
off and the police officer says you know
I'd like to search your car is that all
right their natural inclination is to be
bullied into into say yes
this gives them that understanding that
they do not have to say yes and if they
do say yes there's documentation so that
it's not disputable later
on just to speak on that point the
amendment specifically lines 11 and 12
they all does add a single
sentence original
Bill essentially if an officer fails to
comply with provisions of this
section as a matter of law the search is
going to be deemed to be nonc
consens I would say and this is just
particularly relevant in possession
cases when an officer sech a vehicle the
the real that is at least the majority
of it often can often be whether the
search itself was
lawful if if a person can sense of the
search all the search seizure
Wass is we can spend hours a semester of
lecturing on search and seizure laws
which we certainly won't do that
today but if you consent to the search
all that's out the door here the concern
is that he said she said was whether the
person consented or
not this bill is very
specific great job identifying this
being writing a b body reporting I know
hopefully one day the body caners will
solve that for us but most officers that
I would hope have some type of SM that
would have a recording on as well either
way the point is is that this would just
failure comply with it you're not going
be able to say oh the person sent to
search it does not change any other part
sentence representative
gate thank you Mr chair I don't have a
copy of this amendment was it sent
out I certainly hope
so do the people at home
have I don't have the amendment to this
bill I was it sent electronically or I
certainly don't have one printed
all I think it was on the State website
or state
emails I think Karen sent it Mr chair I
understanding the uh committee assistant
electronically but what I will just I
can although it's prefer to everyone
read it I'll just read the one L
sentence this literally adds one
sentence beginning line 11 it says an
officer who fails to comply with the
requirements of this
paragraph proceeds with a search shall
as a matter of law be conducting a
consent that's all the amendment
acts it doesn't to change any other
fundamental part of
the
bill representative Marson thank you Mr
may second the
bill
represent and my last question is to
new the representative that gives us the
support numbers and opposed numbers did
he give us them yes this piece of
legislation supporting and
opposing represent the
moment and we are
are
there were 96 people who signed in in
support of this bill two who signed in
in opposition and one person who signed
neutral represented
true I apologize Mr chair but I think
you you made a comment that the only
change was conducting a search without
consent but the other change is uh
consent document concept wasn't in the
cor that's not what I had let me just
confirm
that
[Music]
TR I thank you for pointing that up
there is I think the second sentence of
the amendment is also
different point that
out and that line says if a person
consents to aarch the off first document
the person's consent either in writing
or by audio
recording then they conduct The Sur that
was and what that what that does is that
first of all that clarifies that should
be done prior to the search you're going
to document being
done it should be done you
know documenting it after the fact I
successful
wait any anyone else wish to speak
seeing No Hands ready say something give
us a few minutes because we're trying to
get them the
um Phil so we just sent it so he can
take a look at it is he really should
not be voting if he hasn't seen the
bill the people at home not see anyone
am Newman you wish to speak uh I'm not
seeing the bill I looked through all my
emails and I saw a letter I think it was
one that you sent to Karen at sometime
from your iPhone I've seen no no
response to that for an amendment I'll
also be voting against the bill without
amendment you sending it um Mr chairman
I'm in the process of forwarding this to
uh members who are not present in the
room it's a consuming process of adding
One's number manually so I am doing this
as fast as I can and trying to get this
out keep
going keep going you're doing
to well represent Tom me is foring a
amendment
repres yes thank you Mr chairman could
we have the secretary send us those
amendments when they come out to the
addresses that she sends our emails
soon I that's the that's the purpose of
the chair as well um I In fairness that
there was a lot of amendment sent to her
today and she it was oversight on it was
Collective
oversight but for have
representative cleaning up
you
for
[Music]
the chairman point of
order well I make that a parlamentary
aary
I just want to make sure that I have
recognized
question I just have a question would it
be possible for the
chairman if in fact we're going to be
doing a series of executive sessions
today and he has knowledge of of those
executive
of the bills that are going to be exact
that at least we have that much
information so that we can find the
bills and the Amendments and bring to
the chair's attention when we don't have
the appropriate information thank you
Newman I'll answer that question again
while we patiently wait for represent
Conley to forward the
amendment if I were to give a provide a
list of of bills that I anticipated on
on having the executive session on and
gave you a precise order
it would be nothing short of a miracle
that we stuck to that schedule so rather
than create a schedule that I'm not
confident that I can keep and then it
suggests that I'm misleading it what
what not I'm not going to recognize it I
already said I'm not going to recognize
again but I'm just we have some down
time while
represent assisting the committee I will
tell you that it is the rules permit an
executive session to be
conformed um at any time after the
public hearing is that's that's a rule
and that's a house rule it's also
noticed that way in the count I will say
it is a rule that is new for This this
term with that being said I would
prepare for bills to be exec at any
given time
therea uh I will also point out that if
we have 20 minutes of downtime that is
rather than sit around and stay till
9:00 and every gets mad at me we're here
till 9:00 I say we use that 20 minutes
during sunlight and we conduct an
executive session and that's the
discretion the chair and that's how I'm
going to conduct and I'm not g any more
topic col how are we looking it's been
sent via email to members in the
not ask the people the representatives
working remotely to review their emails
please and
[Music]
amendment
emails Saving Time lines 11 and 12 as
well as lines six and seven are
the additions that's
confir please take a minute to
review
[Music]
okay
working do the members working remotely
were they able to access the
do repres Newman you have not been able
amendment
night you have a
question um I if I may uh just to um
some of us just got it so I think
they're in the process of just reading
it over now oh yes I'm just asking if
you have it not just you know I want to
make sure it's actually made it through
cyers
space thank you for the assist your
assistance it is greatly
appreciated texted today because I think
down
[Music]
one
yeah
if you've read the amendment please give
well representative
m i i I do have a have a question on the
on the amendment um the original bill um
uh only required uh the officer to uh
inform the person that the the amended
Bill uh seems to require uh them to
document their consent either in writing
or in audio what I'm curious about is is
does that what happens to that record um
how is that record made is there a form
in existence that would do that um where
are those records stored who's looking
at them is there is there a process
around the paperwork I guess that's my
question a lot of questions yeah I can
answer some of them
so I the best I can do is compare this
to the the Miranda form nor when there's
a charge someone's
arrested they're often read their mirand
and they provide form to sign knowledge
them and it's it's really somewhat
repetitive but it's signed that's part
of the arrest record and then that's
often turned over to the county to the
district attorney is often produced
Discovery so so I would imagine that if
there was a form uh whether it's a paper
form you would be maintained in the same
manner syst with that keep in mind might
not always be an
arrest in addition to that if there was
a video recording
be maintain the same way cases I worked
on has been photographed or videos taken
by officers on their own personal cell
phone devices that has turned over
Discovery so
those are those are ways to do that so
and my understanding from testimony we
heard that some departments already have
a standard form and they already
process I guess another question would
be um given the fact that some
communities may not have that uh and
that the the state police have it should
paper I I do understand that it it is
just a piece of paper but um I spent
half my career moving people off of uh
paper-based benefits enrollment to
online benefits enrollment so I
understand a little bit about uh how one
piece of paper uh can be very
problematic in a process I'm going to go
off pure memory
here my understand 35 says that it's if
the fiscal no is
below a certain threshold actually not
requir I believe that is $10,000 I would
like to say to 35
37 someone wants to fact check
that my understanding is I I don't I
would find it
I would anticipate $10,000 spent on
Che but I I believe in that with that
being said I don't believe in this
case
necessary I actually believe this save a
lot of money because if you don't have
to in possession cases the majority of
the defense involved
inpression hearings this if we if this
is done specifically done the right way
it could clear up some time free up the
off being paid over time hearings fre up
the County attorneys free the course of
course there's actually a lot
ofal savings been actually
now it's hard to quantify what that
would be but I said a lot of these are
are often decided
on
preal
it anyone have opportunity to speak
speak see no hands raised the matter
will be put question this is most about
the pass the question whether to
20249 each up all the r you in favor
please say yay if you are opposed please
say n Vice chairman Welch yes
representative Bert yes representative
hopper for sure representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Maron yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet
pacus
she's
fro she didn't pay your heat bill or
something keep keep
going representative
o'n representative board May
yes I'm sorry did you say yay yes
Newman
yes representative
Bowen
yes representative Conley yes
representative F Knight yes
representative Bradley yes
representative
[Music]
back you not see her Mr chairman she was
just B oh she she's trying to fix it oh
time while we can we got
you my computer went out on
me
yes chairman abis chair vot yes
day mute Muse Mr chair can I clarify
that we were voting on the amendment yes
sorry 19 y
one this time now there motion of to
pass as amended represent harer you're
recognized to make a motion of to pass
as amended I make a motion of to pass
Amendment I'll second
it the second motion pass as amended
thank you Mr
chairman does anyone wish to
discuss seeing No Hands
raised put the question call the RO the
question
is the motion is off the pass as amended
if you are in favor please say yay if
you were opposed please say nay Vice
chairman wilch yes representative bur
yes representative Hopper y
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true good representative
Pratt yes representative Marston yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet G
yes representative
pantelakis
oarn representative bour
yes representative news
Newman representative
Newman
yes representative
Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative Bradley yes chairman
z
z motion amended pass that will be put
on
consent
time close the executive session on
House Bill
45 this
time here's now going to open the
executive session on House Bill
I
begin there was an amendment involving
this is amendment 202-
0397 members participate remotely do
those members have a copy of this
amendment thumbs up or thumbs down would
be
have here recognizing representative
Wallace make a motion pass offer
20213 978 thank you Mr chairman uh yes I
move uh off to pass and offer the
amendment uh the amendment does make a
carve out for individuals under the age
of 20 um that will get caught up in this
particular will there be a second to
that I'll second
you
yes thank you Mr chair sorry for forging
ahead but uh again this amendment
provides a car vot for uh individuals
that haven't attained the age of 20 uh
that may get caught up in this type of
activity uh this amendment is supported
by all stakeholders and uh this bill has
been moving forward through this
committee for the last five years at
this point in time it looks like it's
finally ready at for prime
time
discussion seeing No Hands raised the
matter put the
question question the matter being for
the question is to adopt Amendment 202-
0397 first call the RO if you're in
support of adopting the amendment please
say yay if you were opposed please say
nay ice chairman Welch yes
representative Bert um yes doesn't have
M we're in the
[Music]
voting representative Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay
representative Pratt yes representative
Marston yes the clerk votes yes
representative Harriet gatr no
representative
pantelakis
yes representative
bour um
yes representative muse
no representative Newman
no representative
Balden
no representative Conley
no representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman
abis chair votes yes Mr chairman the
vote is 13 yay
s i voted 13 Y and seven NS the
amendment has been
adopted wall wish toiz for a motion B to
pass as
amended yes Mr chairman thank you I move
that house bill 180 be ought to pass as
amended representative b b you wish to
second that motion pass yes please Mr
chairman the members who are
participating
M I asked several times if you have a
copy of the members provid thumbs up and
thumbs
down the members have a copy of the
amend a thumbs up thumbs down would be
appre getting no reaction
which not responsive so you're trying to
provide a
you repres Wallace thank you Mr chairman
just uh I did just send an image of the
uh Amendment directly to representative
mes via email and it was blocked on his
end
him repr Mar yes thank you Mr chairman
uh my usual question from representative
use support and opposed on this bill
196 on 19 on this bill there were 196
people who were in favor of it and two
opposed repr that two people that were
yes
that see no hands
raised the matter we put the
question the question
is the motion is off pass as
amended if you support the motion of off
passed please say yay you opposed please
say n to clar up all
the vice chairman Welch yes
representative Bert yes representative
Hopper
yes representative green yay
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt
yes representative Marson yay the clerk
votes yes representative Harriet gright
yes representative
pacus
yourself
yes representative
bordon representative news
Newman
Balden yes
representative Conley
yes representative Klein
Knight
yes representative Bradley
yes chairman abis chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is
20 V 20 Y and zero the motion of pass is
this time we'll close the executive
session on House Bill
180 and the criminal justice Public